all right we are
live hi
again hello we're back yes round
two yes after what about two years
right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's been it's been
quite an interesting last two years for
both of us yeah especially the last two
months oh my gosh the last two months
have been more has happened in the last
month than in the last two
years oh right right yeah yeah it was it
was really interesting watching The
Liberation of the mouthpiece to just
allow the
flow yeah
yeah yeah cuz there's there's so much
that wants to actually come out and be
freed and
be be transformed yeah and if there's a
little if there's a little holder inside
that's
going
no well will my and my students think
about me what what will will other
enlightened people think about me yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh I can't I can't say certain
things because I'm trying to be certain
image or whatever yeah yeah oh I
shouldn't say [__] to someone because
that's not
spiritual right or uh or I can't be
angry because it's not equanimous that
one's [__] up that one's is is is
biggest evil on the planet is the
repression of anger because that's the
root chakra and the root chakra is also
Sexual Energy so when we repress anger
we repress our power and
sex
yeah life becomes boring yeah
wow yeah lousy sex well yeah
and when when when has when like that's
a that's a huge Flavor of Life is anger
especially for against Injustice and to
just repress that is out of equanimity
is the dumbest thing that I've ever
heard exactly it's that's that's almost
the Antichrist almost not entirely but
almost because yeah if we repress our
anger we cannot speak up against against
oppression we cannot restore the honor
of God we cannot protect God and The
Feminine on the planet and I think
that's exactly where the spiritual
Community unconsciously and ignorantly
is after because it's only in the
spiritual communities where you hear
that anger is not right it's where
people pretend to be holy mhm and
pretend to be God but God is everything
God is also in me saying to someone I
hate you because they betrayed me but
that's that's God is truth and if that's
the energy that is passing through my
body why should I repress
that wouldn't it be more of an honest
reflection to them if they see me in my
rage because that's then for them
becomes clear what they did to me how I
respond to what has happened so they can
correct themselves and reflect upon
themselves if I act nice well they have
hurt me they cannot integrate the lesson
of that what they did has hurt me what
kind of effect it created with another
human being so all forms of pretend in
my opinion are Corruption of God within
ourselves but also collectively right
all forms of limiting the
flow yeah and it's a very very um
fascinating quote part of the Alchemy
and transformation is is releasing the
limits that are that are repressing the
flow because the flow especially the
anger and the rage especially against
Injustice especially for the new world
especially for grabbing uh spiritual
[__] by their testicles and bringing
them into uh ra rage against Injustice
and pro- New World especially that I
mean otherwise you're going to get a
bunch of people that are just like stuck
in The Matrix with the world economic
Forum dictating their entire lives it's
the exact same thing with being stuck as
a spiritual [__] in a straight jacket
and just having there no difference so
we need the warrior energy to come alive
and that that requires to be tuned into
what it actually what rage and anger
actually is and what what the what the
masculine what the fatherly discipline
is what the catalysts are like when it
comes from that place exactly absolutely
now right now it's the wrong guys that
have that masculine power and anger
those gangster guys those criminals they
hold that power but the awake men who
are here to restore the go honor of God
who manifest new Earth they have to have
that too yes yes they have a way more uh
Noble purpose that they are serving
you're one of them you see so that's
very important and I hope I have been
like a little agent definitely yeah yeah
yeah that's so you you know what's
what's fascinating is that I I caught I
caught that Catalyst right
away right but what's fascinating is I
caught that Catalyst as a reflection to
myself of stop limiting your [__]
mouthpiece and let the rage and God flow
roll and so I I got that through through
you and then uh I caught on to that and
started basically talking about it that
that's a that's an integral part of of
the transformative process it's an
integral part of fully killing
everything inside that's not actually uh
aligned and and then what happened was
it was slow but the whole quote
community that was being
triggered
all you little [__] getting triggered
by narus I [__] love it I love it I
love it all you little tight ass
spiritual [__] I love it I love it I
love it um so when that happened there
was all of that quote like oh my gosh I
don't know what oh it's not holy it's
not holy it's not equanimous it's not
spiritual whatever and then so so I'm
sitting there talking about how
expansive it actually is and then slowly
but surely I'm watching people that are
quote like un unsubscribing or
unfollowing but then I'm watching those
that have had that same
repression get so ignited and so excited
and so passionate and I'm seeing the
masculine Force come alive in this new
Earth Warrior Network I'm seeing it come
alive and it's the most beautiful thing
that's been repressed and so and so now
it's sort of being basically an like an
anchor or a rock as that and then now
seeing the whole reality field morph
around that and and I love that aspect
to it now there have of course been sort
of quote like Reflections about Elegance
or Grace or things like that which are
which definitely takes energetic Mastery
to be extremely balanced and precise and
surgical with with Reflections cuz
sometimes it can definitely go off uh
and begin
uh yeah it's someone is coming from
selfishness or egoic agenda yeah it can
miss the point but someone who's
selfless they don't talk they have they
are being talked and they have the right
to talk whatever they want to talk
because there's no one in there talking
and this is why I also took the right to
like already months ago I started off uh
a video about seductive promiscuity
energy and then I ended it with like
you're a [__] why would a man want to
marry a slot right okay wait wait before
we get into the Divine Union stuff
because this is so spot on I Divine yeah
yeah yeah exactly you no no this is the
opp you're talking about the opposite of
divine Union Yes
Yes anti- Divine Union Yes yes the
Antichrist in that sense so I want to
before we get into that I want to
mention another thing which is another
thing that I'm going to grill um the
viewers on is that I think that you guys
for uh being mad at uh maram I think
you're wrong because she traveled across
the planet across an ocean to go on the
number one men's podcast on like
whatever Fitness and masculinity and
stuff like
that
no yeah yeah yeah but that's that's how
they brand it that's how they brand it
right and
news crazy thing though is that you you
went to talk about what you're talking
about now and you went on to some you
went on to some uh podcast that had over
a million subscribers and whatnot that I
think over a quarter million people
watch the episode or something like that
there are I think thousands of comments
or something a bunch of people
supporting you all this kind of stuff
and so basically what I and then and
then here's the thing the people that
are mad at you for doing that and
speaking truth and sitting in it and
actually doing that they're the same
ones that sit and don't do anything and
sit and and just complain on the
internet about things that are
triggering them so anyway [__] you guys
[__] you guys for taking no action as c
as Catalyst for for transforming Earth
and Consciousness [__] you guys because
that's the most arrogant thing to do is
to sit back and to because that's the
kind of work that needs to happen we
need to be ignited to go into these
types of of transformational scenarios
and stay steadfast as the world I mean
there's no other there's no other way
but actually igniting it yeah so want to
say that yeah amazing thank you I I
fully support you in what you've just
said because indeed it's the biggest
arrogance to just sit back and be like I
know better than her and uh why is she
saying this word why that's not loving
that's not compassionate well you're
sitting there because you have zero
power because power stems from the root
chakra and if anger and sexuality is
repressed you're not moving in anywhere
yes you're just sitting behind a
computer watching porn and commenting on
nonel stuff that's the max you can
do yes yes that that uh quote like
fapping culture or sing culture or
whatever whether it's to the government
or corporations or uh only fans or
whatever satanic script that are running
that are creating all those sexual
distortions um or if it's even if it's
sing and Outsourcing one's power on the
spiritual journey instead of being
[__] punched back right into the open
space and purity of mind and God and
then being able to be ignited from that
place to build but any any sing at all
any simping at all is satanic and it's
to be annihilated as part of this new
Earth um ignition so [__] hate the
sing man the sing is such a [__] and
it's like yeah yeah yeah go
ahead yeah absolutely well I'm not sure
what topic do you want to dive in first
uh we talk about um yeah whatever we
discussed remember we've been we've been
already uh hitting a good amount of the
like the foundation of things
um so well let's go ahead and um and so
I gave that preface about the uh the
Divine or sacred unions and whatnot so
um it's it's actually kind of crazy that
one does not actually know what is
possible by uh through the Divine Union
or through the sacred Union because
through that this is how it's been sort
of HP coming up more and more is that um
by quote turning off the satanic
programs or deconditioning the satanic
programs around oh I will just you know
[__] whenever whoever any [__] time
and then kick people to the curb or
whatever all that kind of all that kind
of [__] or like uh in I like what you
said it's like like like girls and guys
shouldn't be like inviting each other
over into their houses and stuff at
night and whatnot like you meet out in
public you meet out in public over
coffees or whatever get to know each
other then you get to know each other's
Ames and whatnot I mean it's way this is
way more traditional and you don't know
sex until marriage yeah and so but then
what's what what is happening when that
happens is in a way the entire bodily
energy the the energy of divinity
basically itself is beginning to
activate and release what you'll never
get as codes you'll release codes that
you'll never get if you don't do that so
nice okay so go ahead and take it from
take it from there um Amen brother amen
sister let's go hallelujah
hallelujah this bookc has turned around
round and
around Messiah returned oh okay more
more on that later go okay yeah yeah
well yeah
um yeah I think yeah when I entered the
the the what they call like reality of
Creation Kingdom of Heaven whatnot
basically B Bliss as your Eternal home
and everlasting ecstasy and Bliss at all
times even when you're shouting at
someone because it's relevant or I don't
know blocking someone you know all that
kind of immature
things
um I realized that actually I feel very
uncomfortable being with one man in one
room who is not my husband or who yeah
basically that and that I feel very um I
don't fear anything like I'm I'm on
Instagram calling people [__] and I'm
recording video and saying whatever I
want to say like there's literally no
fear in my body but when I think about
having sex outside of marriage I get
terrified it's like God fear is the only
fear that is actually uh allowed is to
fear something that lowers your
vibration and casts you out of that
reality of creation cast you out of the
kingdom of heaven so that reminded me
that uh so basically fearing
dishonor exactly fearing to dishonor
yourself because dishonoring yourself is
dishonoring God and I am not a religious
person at all um I'm someone who has
been striving to realize my true nature
Enlightenment was my only purpose for
for quite some time so I dedicated
myself to that and through that I I
liberated my Sexual Energy because that
is a requirement in order to realize
your true nature because sex is God God
is sex it's that's like the penetration
of the masculine and The Feminine of
fullness and emptiness dancing together
that is sex that's actually what we're
perceiving right now yes exactly oh it's
so good we are sex right now I [__]
everything is that yes yeah everything
there is there is only sex basically yes
yes so through that I realized that
Sexual Energy uh was sacred and it had
to be protected and also like I've also
been raised with values my dad is like a
bit of a he's not religious nor
traditional he has himself never married
for God he was actually against um he's
for pro values but against Authority
oppressing people in the name of God so
he was actually he he felt that very
painful uh to see that people people
were using religion to suppress people
and basically every religion almost
every religion has been doing that um
except for the bahai religion which is
quite new so a lot of people don't even
know that that religion exists is
basically a messenger that came after
Prophet Muhammad but acknowledged all
religions and all spiritual paths so and
also um announced the return of Christ
as Spirit within a man and as
Consciousness for all of us so um yeah
through that I've realized that it's
actually very unnatural for a woman to
have sex outside of honor and I started
to speak about that more in indirect
ways and also uh warn women that are
came in contact with me and just to be
clear it's also dishonorable for men to
have sex outside of Honor yeah
absolutely but men don't feel it that
way because men use sex to test women to
see if they're worthy to marry or
not
that's why a man uh does not feel
fear to have
sex that's why a man um will probably
not say no if you offer yourself on the
first or second date if you're not
completely ugly and and attractive to
him because he will use that if he's has
a slightly bit of interest in you he
will use that to test you even good men
do
that it's like an in internal wiring
system and when you prove yourself to be
very easy you prove yourself to be
disloyal to God disloyal to your own
body and then the man subconsciously
remembers internally that oh that means
that she's also not going to be loyal to
me so then they lose interest in
you haven't that happened to you that
you are intimate with someone and then
all a sudden you're like what happened I
lost all interest in her you as a man in
your masculine energy deemed her as not
loyal because if she is a slow Theory if
she can easily come to you then you can
easily lose her because then she can
also easily attach to some other guy
that she sees and gives her a
few so so so there's a buildup of secure
attachment in the Divine Union yeah yeah
that's very important because we have to
understand this a man and a woman does
not attach for the same thing a man can
fall in love with you through his heart
through his emotions and because he
feels attracted to you or he he finds
you beautiful he finds that you are the
one for him he can completely fall in
love with you completely
madly without even having to touch you
or maybe even haven't spoken to you but
a woman she's Savage because she's
protected by God she will not just fall
in love like that even if a man proposes
she can still
stay stay within her uh mean nature and
be like that doesn't mean anything
because she has not been attacked
attached yet because a woman attaches
herself through physical intimacy and
that is a protection of God because when
you place intimacy where it should be
after marriage a woman can only attach
to you after
marriage and then when she's attached
you will probably not just dump her
because you have just married her so she
is safe from heartbreak that's how God
protect a woman from heartbreak but
apparently God thought you guys are
tough so you can you can fall in love
earlier and you can have a heartbreak
because you're you're tough you're a man
you should just be a man and man up but
for women it was like no you're my
flower I'm GNA protect you yes
yes yes yes and that that is so
beautiful like having like an actual
flower that you can
basically that that's like the how
there's I think there's two I in a way
there's two things true there's the true
love side of it the Divine Union side of
it which kind of gives you something to
die for it gives you a reason to live
for for your family for your children
you know it gives you that reason to
live and then there's also the mission
which is the same thing but the and the
mission is the re realization of
consciousness of what it truly is and
then to build the new world and those
two things are are the same thing but
they're they're both required for you to
die into you can't you can't have just
one of those things in in other words
meaning if you're trying to be quote A
New Earth quote Warrior or just like
being someone realized whatever but you
don't have the true love the Divine
Union side of things there's going to be
all kinds of energy leakages all kinds
yeah yeah yeah it's it's inevitable
because once a man truly wakes up to his
honor to his masculine energy to his
allows his anger to flow through
whenever necessary he will have a lot of
sexual energy and that is actually a
good thing because that's the power yes
that's the the the force of power God
gave that to man and made them like in
the like lions because apparently there
is a relevance for that it's not there's
nothing uh weird about it or there's
nothing nasty about it it's just it
becomes nasty when it's being placed
outside of Honor because then it's where
it leaks to the reality of survival and
it empowers the victim consciousness
because pleasure is pain Buddha said it
uh and it empowers um the corrupt Army
that energy that is arrogant and is
working
against
light
because we as humans are not created
evil we are not created unconscious we
are not created dump we are not created
judgmental or uh full of Shadows and
Trauma that's a lower self and the lower
self is being is very suceptible and
very um can be affected by those corrupt
entities prior Enlightenment that's why
it's very important for people who are
not realize their true nature who don't
have that full protection from from from
Evil is to protect themselves by knowing
what's right what's wrong because that's
how you can um protect yourself against
harm and Corruption and Distortion Until
you realize your true nature then you
will still live uh life uh
relatively enjoy you know and have less
of like these karmic right snow storms
and snow balls that just bang hit you
right back into your face just because
you were ignorant about what what is
what is Honorable and what is not so dis
dishonor equals
Karma yeah for sure
because why why do women seduce uh men
can you can you see me yeah okay
you're a bit stuck on my end but oh
you're still you're still coming through
clearly oh okay okay great so uh why why
if you go back to the story of Adam and
Eve she's portrayed as The Sinner she
gave the Apple to a Adam Adam why
because it's the woman who seduces a man
a man does not seduce a woman he can't
because he's not that attractive a man
uh that can never seduce me into to sex
because I I don't work that way as a
woman but I as a woman I can seduce a
man because it's very hard for a man to
say no if you just undress yourself and
I don't know start dancing or kissing or
do whatever for a man it's like 10 or
100 times harder to say like you know
what this is dishonoring [__]
off but for a woman it's it's
um it's it's easier but these days what
you see is that even the woman finds
herself being seduced by men into
sleeping together because she has been
depolarized and through this subject we
come to the subject of the Antichrist
which I am absolutely convinced of that
the Antichrist is this depolarized
feminine energy it's a
woman in a female body but embodying
masculine energy putting on long nails
and lips and makeup to look feminine but
inside a man transgender basically and
is it the same thing for a very feminine
male body I would say that is also
Antichrist but those are not that empty
because those are not evil and those are
not like
um mean because men are never that mean
or evil as women can be a toxic woman is
10 times worse than a toxic feminine man
he's just basically weak he can just not
build new Earth he's just like a weak
being but a a depolarized woman is an
evil being she starts to work against
God prevent unions from happening lie
corrupt things um I've seen so much more
evil throughout my life uh coming from
women than from men men are just
straight when they fight with men it's
like you fight and then you make it up
and then it's done with women they can
go on for years resenting each other and
you know building up stuff within their
themselves so women have that like more
of that um because women are have been
given the sword of Khali energy so they
hold that that's also been given by God
to protect
themselves but they're using that not to
protect themselves but to attack other
people because they have been invaded by
those corrupt entities and those corrupt
entities they invade uh women so they
become like a seductress they they
because they're invaded by those corrupt
entities they start perceiving
themselves as unworthy and low and not
good enough and in this they they don't
find themselves worthy to ask for
marriage they don't dare to walk up to a
man and say hey I like you do you like
me but I'm only available for marriage
because they're afraid that the man is
going to say [__] you and they going to
feel rejected or that the man is going
to be like no I don't like you you're
not beautiful or you're not smart so
they try to walk away around it by first
dating and seducing and having sex and
hoping that the man then will commit to
them but nine of the 10 times that never
happens because the man is like yeah I
don't know the sex was nice but I'm
definitely not going to marry you and
then they leave and they get that
approval and that confirmation that oh
you not good enough and then they start
the whole circles all
over and in between that well when men
and women are cultivating Sexual Energy
either through Screen through phone or
through actual sex every that energy
that goes through pleasure because it's
not sacred it's not uh true love so it's
just solely for pleasure and distraction
bad energy becomes the dinner of those
corrupt entities yes yes those corrupt
entities become stronger how do you
think they became so strong they they
invaded the whole planet and they made
us greedy and weak and slow and dump and
judgmental and arrogant they in they
became stronger through SE through
energy Sexual Energy the biggest current
life force current on this planet they
took that because we it started off Eve
we started to dishonor ourselves and
let's be honest we all know this we all
no this but at the same time we all
think like it doesn't matter interesting
so yes yes so even though even um the
Like the quote um the corrupt programs
that are Contracting Earth from its
expansive possibility even the ones that
are like um like in the food system or
in the pharmaceutical system or in the
media system or the war and separation
or those things even those even if you
gain awareness of those and whatnot and
you can uh be more clearly
light there's still the one that you
would say is the most root of them all
which is Sexual Energy being corrupted
is even more
dishonorable than any of those other
things so Mastery of discernment and
propaganda like in your media is less
important than keeping radical honor at
your Sexual Energy Center absolutely so
then that that is the well or the source
of the entire Kundalini of the bodily
system yeah so so so then so then
our by by holding honor there what
happens is then all these other codes
get activated and come online and then
there's a the there's a there's a
transformation that happens of the
entire the Earthly system the oh out out
of where oh my gosh like I you wrote it
like stop being pigs and be Celestial
beings and I was like God that's [__]
that's [__] perfect you know we take
we take these nuggets you know I I see
your nuggets you know and I take them
and I like I I I I kind of add add a add
another like lens that includes you know
whatever wherever um these codes and
yeah I really I really like uh this this
pointing I think I think everyone knows
like you said that it's like everyone's
talking about it there's like probably I
don't know thousands of videos that are
are going up I don't even know how often
every month at least like all around
what should we do about porn addiction
what should we do about uh I can't find
I can't find a wife I can't you know I I
messaged you that there's a whole um
movement in the masculine culture called
passport
Bros so so These Guys these guys who are
sick of Western women like you said that
are very depolarized and Hyper masculine
that what they do is they go and travel
to different countries around the world
where there are more traditional
feminine values yeah and then they will
find wives in those areas because they
know they're magnetizing towards what
they feel like is a more pure Divine
Union in that's yeah yeah absolutely and
you know what it's so way it's more
simpler than we think it is the moment
you decide you're only available the for
the one and you're not going to settle
for anything less and you stop [__]
around with snacking around basically
that's when you God will will Grace you
with that person but you have to come to
that point where you're just sick of
superficial context because you realize
that a a slot can never offer you what
your your your the other half of your
soul can the way that she can support
you and be there for you and also uh
that loyalty that you get from the
feminine that looks up to you and
supports you and is there for you
unconditionally that is Priceless we
have to understand that men are actually
not after sex because if men were after
sex they would marry a hoe and have sex
with her all day but they don't do that
they're after loyalty yes because that's
what makes them feel most respectful and
most honorable and a man would at all
times prefer respect over
love yeah for a woman it's the opposite
like you can crack a joke with
me but if you don't if I I don't feel
loved I I don't feel
seen But if a man doesn't feel respected
he doesn't feel seen nice right but you
know you can crack jokes with each other
that doesn't mean you disrespect each
other but but you know within a re
within a relationship is where you where
a man sincerely advises you something
and you know he has his best intentions
for you and you choose not to listen to
him but follow a western agenda that
tells you you should earn more money you
should put your ass out there but like
this is invading our culture massively
and we have all these high people in
high position showing a very false uh
example to the feminine like I saw a
documentary of Beyonce uh after five or
six months that she gave birth uh she
started to work very hard on this new
show that she was building and she was
burning herself out and I was looking at
it I was like wait you have a husband
who does
who provides for you who has honored you
through marriage who tells you I'm sure
he tells her that she's beautiful and is
there for her and you choose a show over
being with your newborn child and being
with your husband and enjoying those
sacred moments that you have because I'm
sure Jay-Z is very busy too and he
should be because he's a man or like the
Kim K and Kanye example and that's why
men cheat men cheat because not because
they want sex with another woman but
because they don't feel the feminine
energy they feel like they don't have a
feminine next to them so they want that
and they start to find someone else
that's why you have all these examples
of these women that tell like oh I'm so
beautiful like um what's that woman
called the most beautiful um actress
cion Diaz she got cheated on and then
people like well when she if she got
cheated on then men are just all
cheaters because she's the most
beautiful woman on the planet well he
cheated on her because she was in her
masculine she was doing all she was
choosing career over the masculine and
the masculine will never feel great at
that because deep down he feels that
she's betraying him she's disrespecting
him because she's choosing something
else over supporting him and enjoying
the union that they have together which
in my opinion is the highest achievement
for a woman is a harmonious enjoyful and
love building a loving relationship and
investing all of herself in that Union
and being like this nurturing enjoyable
light of the two because let's honest a
man does not have that much lightness in
his life because he has responsibilities
and he feels a calling to serve his
purpose so he that's why he he the Adam
and manifested Eve from his rib to have
a supportive Force who's not equal who
is not equal everyone who says that
women and men are equal is lying I
cannot work as hard as you can I cannot
work as much as hours that you can I
can't do that if I do that I get burned
out and what I also see around me women
that I know spiritual women normal women
they all have some sort of like sickness
in like the uterus a high HPV is
prevailing because we're all having sex
with each other like
pigs uh people have cysts in their
breasts uh people have hormonal
imbalances why because there people are
infertile
uh people that trying to have a baby for
10 years they can't conceive because
there is the body is disregulated it's
NE was never our body was never meant to
conduce so much masculine energy to do
everything on ourselves already for me
driving a car is hard like yesterday I I
was driving the car I made so much
mistakes and then I realized wow I
should never drive longer than 20
minutes because it's it takes so much
effort for me to focus now I clearly
understand why in Saudi Arabia they
don't let a woman drive because of
course they the women are unconscious so
they're not in the Bliss state that I am
their their brain is not in a flow state
so they can drive most likely if they're
smart but I when I'm I return back into
my Natural Essence and I restore
restored the the the the little
depolarization that I had I was never
severely depolarized but of course also
affected by the Western uh agenda and I
could drive I could never drive like
longer than one hour than I already felt
like I hate this I always hated car
driving but I did it but now I just
cannot do it more than 50 minutes it's
it's hard because a brain that is high
on love which a woman should be because
she's the embodiment of love she should
be high on the love of God she cannot
focus because she's not
masculine so she either needs a driver
or or her partner to bring her to places
or she needs to take a train or a cycle
like like I do I take I rent a site a
bike all the time that's fine I'll I'll
I'll chime I'll chime in here so you you
know what's fascinating when that Sexual
Energy is actually channeled into the
Divine Union in honor is that um and in
the polarities in balance is that the
nourishment that comes with from the
feminine into the masculine it's
basically an amplifier of the new Earth
mission of emptiness and love perfect
balance for the new world yeah and it's
in ways that is not possible outside of
that Union absolutely so if you're
looking for quote the your calling you
know if you're really looking for your
calling you will find it you'll find
like very like enti it's like kind of
alluring like little hooks outside of
the Divine Union you'll be like well
this is kind of like it or this is kind
of like it or whatever but then when you
really start honing in on that deepest
Well
Point you'll you'll be fascinated by how
much those quote code the blueprints the
codes they amplify like insanely like
amplify insanely and then it's always
fascinating watching how like the the
woman will will comment about how uh
holy [__] like you're like you're really
able to structure like the flow of love
and oceanic into the new world like kind
of thing like and and that's what men
are excited about the masculine force is
like excited to build something for
their wives their families and for the
new world for the totality that's the
masculine is all about excitement and
systems engineering and like prosperity
and abundance and all this kind of cool
stuff yeah the masculine are givers
they're the the giving energy let's be
honest a man feels very joyful when he
buys a gifts for for his woman and gives
it to her and she's all grateful for
that because that that's the energy you
can also see that in the sexual organs
who's the receiver and who's the giver
so the the masculine is always the the
the giving energy and he is the more he
loves his his partner the more he will
be dedicated and committed to create a
safe place on Earth so she can freely
walk there with a beautiful dress and
not be harassed or be oppressed yes yes
see and I I think that's the new Earth
we have been in a reality where women
have been repressed they were they had
to wear headscarves and then they had to
wear skirts in Christianity or like vice
versa and and now we're in in a reality
where women are putting their ass on the
Instagram and that's not even triggering
men they're like yeah I've already seen
so much ass on like I can see all asses
on the internet now charging or charging
whatever 20 bucks a month for a guy to
watch them like [__] rub their [__]
or whatever they're doing
knowly the complete those two are crazy
like head scarfs or only fans like what
the
[__] yeah so we we we writing both
extremes we have been writing both
extremes and we are still writing those
and the newer is all about balance where
the woman can wear beautifully uh can
wear dresses but not like trashy because
she honors herself she respects herself
and she's not lowering herself out of
this sense of worthiness to think that
oh all men should give me compliments
because somehow I find some benefit or
relevance in that leeching energy of men
that are never serious with you but they
still want to throw some energy at you
because they think you're sexy but what
does a woman get out of that nothing so
in the new Earth there will be women who
are be radiant beautiful feminine and
expressing interesting a woman doesn't
get anything out of men sing to her
exactly nothing like for me it's
disgusting that's why I blocked a few
men from my Instagram call It Out Sister
call it out yeah I was I placed some
pictures and actually in the masculine
it's the same briefly I just want to say
that for the masculine it's also doesn't
give you anything to get simped on by
the Mas by the masculine actually really
the Divine Warrior masculine if it even
gets a tiny bit of like energy of like
sing or worshiping or what not there's
an immediate punch back of like sit in
your Divinity as as a king as a queen
sit in your Divinity and so yeah anyway
go ahead keep keep going on men sing
women yeah yeah it's just like it's just
a a very toxic Dynamic nobody's getting
out because you both are in this
scarcity and lack victim Consciousness
state where you're like just lowering
yourself day by day and you don't get
anything out of it but let's not talk
about that because that's boring what's
interesting is to see that we're heading
towards a a time where we will finally
be balanced where men can admire women
out of
sincerity and and honor them in their
beauty without oppressing them or uh
exploiting them because that's also a a
dynamic that has been started yes the
woman is responsible for protecting her
Sexual Energy because she she she's
vulnerable yeah you don't feel used by a
woman if you have sex with her well you
can feel like that but most likely you
won't feel that as much you'll be like
well whatever you forget about it but a
woman can feel used because a woman
doesn't fall doesn't women F fall in
love through sex and and and women start
to attach through sex men don't have
that men test women to see how easy or
or or or how easy she is and who she is
so Lo
faithful yes how loyal is she to towards
herself and God but this is a very
unconscious wiring like men that never
think about spirituality or loyal
loyalty or God God they or God or God
less spiritual [__] somehow
dishonorable spiritual [__] somehow
yeah yeah and this is this is
interesting because yeah if we restore
like before New Earth can never manifest
before masculine feminine energy balance
is restored it's impossible new Earth
cannot
manifest we if we are still uh leaking
all that energy to the reality of Bal to
the reality of victim Consciousness the
reality of pleasurous pain the reality
of I'm not I'm not worthy to meet the
the one for myself so I just distract
myself on Tinder that's victim
Consciousness right right and and
because you're settling for something
that is way less amazing so so you think
you must be thinking that you're less
deserving right yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah swiping on Tinder is unworthiness
holy [__] it is it is because you're
you're the one for you she's walking
around somewhere she is yeah and she's
waiting for you and she wants that too
but you can only meet each other when
you both decide you're not going to
settle for anything less right right
exactly okay so so this is fascinating
so in the the sexual root being
completely sealed by Honor is the core
of new Earth manifestation
absolutely I love that so much so
resonant so resonant yeah and it's it's
really something that has to go viral
because the awake community and the
people that remember honor the the ex
Christians or the Christians and the
ex-muslims or the Muslims everyone who
thinks of themselves that I love God in
what way possible in a spiritual way or
in a religious way any way feels
connected to God will REM remember and
will take and we be like oh [__] yes
this is why we're suffering know
especially when they start tasting what
power comes from locking the sexual root
in honor because the power is
unprecedented it's like nothing else
it's like the entire body becomes
activated in un unspeakable ways it's
like whatever you're seeking actually um
is already obviously here as we all know
but by by um locking the sexual root in
honor there's an activation of what
you're quote looking for that you've
never oh there it is that you've never
felt before with the confetti animation
that just
happen that's yes yes yes some sometimes
I get animations on the system I love it
it's a great timing great
timing holy
cow wow right and the the relief of
sitting in the honor relief of sitting
in honor a aka the relief of not being
hooked into satanic programs exactly
because that's the biggest satanic
program it is because let's be honest
for a man the most seducing thing after
the number one is women why would a man
work hard get a nice car get a beautiful
house uh and get money on his bank if
he's not getting a woman who's beautiful
and who respects him there's no there's
no point of that like men do that
because they want to be with a woman
because true love is the highest thing
for everyone we're here for love I mean
that's why God individuated itself in
the masculine and The Feminine to find
itself again through each other and
become conscious of itself through the
polarity because that's the only way
that you can feel that charge you cannot
feel it if you're all Oneness you need
to have polarity you know those two
magnets that just like yeah yeah this
each other and then come back to each
other and this each
other that that play that they play yeah
you can play that with yourself you need
some mirror to to do that for you and
more purified they are the the higher
the stakes become and the more pain
there is and the more like the more you
feel you
know think of yourself like the most
person on the planet all of a sudden you
realize you're in [__] so so TR so
exactly so TR so true love is the um the
embodiment of God's intention for
feeling what manifestation is or what
creation is absolutely and this is also
another thing that I want to add in I've
been observing men like I'm on Instagram
since I've been um interested no since I
um
woke up to the fact that I don't know
[__] since I woke up to that fact I
started to express myself on YouTube and
Instagram and through that expression uh
there were more quote unquote
self-realized men or men that claim
themselves to be realized that uh
started to follow me and I start to like
look at what they doing also talking
about nality and things like that and
I've observed them and I've seen uh also
people here in Holland that are like
ecstatic dance gjs and that are also
awake and some of them are realized and
enlightened whatnot I've seen their
expression change once they got into a
relationship with a man and started to
have sex they immediately started to
post less things they immediately
started to create less things like their
whole expression and Radiance started to
change I've literally seen enlightened
men be complete different person when
they were in a relationship with a woman
that are dishonoring because you're not
married you shouldn't have sex with each
other and when they were not like two
like it's like paradise and hell and it
was so strange for me to see because I
was like isn't that guy like enlightened
why is he suffering and then some would
like tell all these stresses that they
had and I was like how are you stressing
about all those things you should be you
enlightened like you have that on your
Instagram you're doing Retreats and
you're doing things and then they would
talk about things and also worry about
money and I was like how can you believe
in scarcity if you're enlightened so for
me it was like crazy I because I didn't
make that connection because me too I
also thought those religious rules are
just outdated and it's just for
religious cons that's what I thought so
I also didn't understood but now I do
when you have sex outside of Honor you
get cast out of the kingdom of heaven so
this is why a lot of people that are
enlightened or so realize they go they
have faces where they're in Bliss and
then they go back to the lower self and
start to integrate shadows and start to
integrate lessons and I've had that too
I've had a relationship with someone
that I also did a retreat Retreats with
and um I was in Bliss and ecstasy I was
recording myself in Hawaii I was doing
so many things that were so enjoyable
and as soon as we became intimate like
he was really committed to me like he
wanted to he was actually the one who
wanted to be in a relationship and and
eventually we got into a relationship
because he he wanted that and I kind of
was like okay but I just didn't see a
future with him because of the I didn't
feel like as attracted to him as I
wanted to feel if I would think of a
future with someone and he was also way
older than me but I still like respected
him because he honor like he he
committed to me and he was like
completely in love with me so I was like
okay this man treats me right why should
I not be with him you know but then all
of a sudden all these distortions became
like my reality changed and I never made
that connection I started to have all
these shadow aspects that I had to
integrate and Trauma work started to
become relevant all of the sudden
seemingly and then I I subscribed to
Scott kbby his platform because I
thought like well I'm not in Bliss
anymore so that means that I need to
work on myself on my Shadows maybe
that's the integration part but no I was
just casted out of the kingdom of heaven
and we didn't even see each other that
often we saw each other a few times a
month because he worked a lot of like uh
in other countries and he were he lived
in another city and we both had a kid so
we it wasn't even that often but there
was just this this honoring that you are
with someone without honor that made it
made me reside in that lower self
reality while I was self-realized so I
was also confused so I started on my
channel also talk about emotions trauma
work uh that being relevant but my
vibration was just lower because I was
dishonoring God by being in a
relationship with a man without marriage
and being with someone that I know is
not the one for me I never saw him as
the one for me so I settled for
something that was less because I
thought I'm going to learn things from
him and he's way smarter and wiser than
me guess what he projected a lot of his
insecurities to me we were both
self-realized but then when I wouldn't
answer uh a message for two three hours
he would already be irritated and
project that on me and I was the one who
was constantly saying like well we
shouldn't be in a relationship because
like I I don't necessarily see why the
benefit of a relationship should be here
because like we see each other when we
see each other and we meet up when we
meet up like I don't need a relationship
to love you I I was the one who was
saying that completely influenced by
these non-el aspects but I realized
these non-el theories but I realize now
that that was just me not being in love
with him because if you are truly in
love with someone you're not going to
say that to to them you're just going to
say like no I want to be yours and you
should be mine and like I want that
safety which is also very relevant
because a woman cannot feel safe if she
constantly has to think like oh tomorrow
you might be gone so you're surrendering
to someone who's not even holding you so
a woman can never surrender and that's
what you see in this uh whole world
women and men are together with the
woman never surrenders because there is
no marriage there is no promise a woman
needs this in order to surrender because
she knows she will be laying there and
she will not fall on the ground but when
a man does not provide that she she she
stays strong she's not going to
surrender because she has to hold
herself there's no no hand for her to
lay in so this is also what you see
these women become th they're like okay
we're equal I'm going to work you're
going to clean the toilet you're going
to cook for me you're going to do this
and if you you're not going to tell me
what I should wear or should not wear
you're not going to tell me if I can
have guy friends or no you should not be
jealous I should put my ass on Instagram
and you should not even mention anything
about it you see that in very high
positions you see Ronaldo Cristiano
Ronaldo sitting in the audience
pretending he's happy for his wife but
inside he just thinks like [__] what the
[__]
I don't like this because she's doing a
dancing contest with uh with to prove
herself to the world that she is not a
GUI store girl that she's someone who's
like talented and like Kim Kardashian
you know but Kim Kardashian also got
divorced because her man returned more
to honor and became more Christian and
he said to her I don't want that wet luk
for the Grammys you've been like a
prostitute your whole life Jack I value
you you're my wife we have kids together
we have enough money you don't need more
money you don't need more publicity
everyone already knows who you are
because your ass is big you have the
biggest ass of the world so you don't
need that dress wear something else what
did she do no we already worked on that
team for too long on that dress this
kind of [__] designer designed it
for me so um I'm going to wear that
dress so she Dishonored him she
disrespected him so Fame attention from
other men and women and money is more
important to her than obeying her
husband sexual leakages yeah exactly and
then when she comes home she puts on
pajamas but what should a man think then
like you seduce other people you're
beautiful for them but when you come
home you're in your pajamas so what am I
hear then like a
prank
Punk prank just a joke to you so he
feels disrespected that's what they
divorce and God cursed her because she
will for a very long time not be honored
by any man because she prefers being a
prostitute that's she she is a
seductress why should a sedu be honored
by God by a man through God she wants
money she apparently she doesn't have
enough money and she doesn't have enough
attention so she chose that instead of
true love Kenya truly loved her how how
crazy would have it been if that Divine
Union if the Sexual Energy could have
been Honorable in that specific Divine
Union and what could have it yeah
birthed yeah yeah but but she's already
uh corrupted by those evil entities
because when when a woman has enough sex
outside of Honor she gets like this
masculine uh armor because only a man
can have a lot of sex and not feel
anything a woman cannot have that
because she constantly feels used and
also afraid and also threatened like
will he be with me will he dump me like
in order to to kind kind of survive that
you need a bit of like hardness and
toughness so you have to become more
masculine in order to hang around with
men without honor so that is what
happening with a lot of women that's why
they they distort their face and they're
put on a lot of makeup to camouflage the
fact that they're not a true woman
anymore they're like
transgender so a lot like these lips and
everything and breasts and implants is
all an attempt to confuse the man it's
like I am a man inside but you should
benefit me so I'm going to make you
think like I'm very sexual and sensual
which is an aspect of feminine energy so
I'm going to put on my lips very big and
uh fill fill them with fillers and put a
lot of makeup and like pretend I'm very
feminine so you will be like lurt and
seduced but once you have me you'll
realize that I'm a man because I care
about money and fame and if you cannot
offer that to me then you're not good
enough for me I'm not going to listen to
you that's what you see in these only
fans girls what happened on that podcast
when they get can get money out of you
they they respect you but if you if
you're a Brokey they just ignore you
because they're not loyal to you they're
loyal to money even if they say that
they're loyal to to you they're not they
betray you because they have sold their
soul for something else than honor of
God a woman who doesn't honor God also
never honor a man because if a woman
doesn't honor God on number one priority
then she has a different agenda and her
agenda is different is money Fame attent
so she cannot get that from from him she
will get it somewhere else so she will
always that's what you see these women
who have everything from their masculine
like these woman of Ronaldo Jay-Z Kim
kardashan like they like they are being
provided for they are being uh like when
they have a birthday they pull out a new
house a new car whatever whatever you
want they pull out for you they tell you
you're beautiful you can do what your
appearance whatever you want but it's
still not enough a new spaceship or
whatever yeah and it's still not enough
they go out they go out and burn
themselves out to to pull out a show to
get attention and approval and
compliments from people telling Beyonce
wow you're a badass you pulled out a
show while your kid was with a nanny and
wanted to held by you and your man
wanted to spend that little sacred and
intimate time that you have and as a
Revenge JayZ cheated on her not because
he wants to be with another woman he
he's loyal to her he loves her he loves
her more than anything here but he just
proved he just that was just like an
action to prove her something like you
you dishonor me so it's like an anger
action to draw her attention you know
like he blocked her in that way
because she followed someone
else something else so there were two
instead of one too and a man doesn't
like that he wants to be a number
one
right
well um there's well there's a couple
threads to pull but I I I'm loving this
um honorable honor with sexual energy
and how that manifests the new world I
love that so much and and it's felt
right away in terms of again those codes
that are basically released from the
Divine Union you can't find those codes
anywhere else that's really one of your
quote feedback loops into knowing that
that's the core key like yeah yeah I I
love that part of it and then there's a
there's a question uh in the chat about
um would love to hear thoughts on the
homosexual experience and how it
integrates into what we're talking about
I know I've heard you um kind of trying
to talk about what like queerness how it
integrates into kind of what we're
talking about and I know that I've uh
had experiences there and I and I've
wanted to talk about it um on the on the
show also so I'm I'm just going to use a
a little bit to say this
that if you're still not quote
genderless Consciousness if you're still
not that then sometimes what's happening
down at the root is an
identification with being a man it's
like an identification with being um
like your bi like hardcore like ident
it's like a grip on your identity and
also you're not in that way you're not
technically balanced because you haven't
learned what feminine surrender is so
for the man and I've had I've had a
couple experiences like this that I've
been important where I've been with a
man to uh in both ways in both being
penetrated and penetrating because it's
been the learning of what surrender is
the balancing of into the the with the
feminine and polarity and then also it's
then learning how to hold men and be
held by men so that way you don't create
artificial war with your brothers in the
new world okay so so that's how that's
how it worked out here and
then um and then now it's like uh the
it's it's now it's obvious like what I
am what this is and then the coming
together with the feminine body right to
come together into the Divine Union that
way and the the codes that come from
that so it's almost like it can come up
as an ex as an experience in the Journey
of the male body to um to to to learn
those lessons to to to uh dissolve those
contractions and the conditionings
around it but don't get quote stuck
there is one way to to put it is uh well
you know whatever the flow of God is but
if if you're if you're especially if
you're quote feeling like you're queer
or whatever and you and you're like
playing around with that that then you
can integrate it back into the Divine
Union of the male man and woman for the
the new Earth so that that would be my
response yeah absolutely and do you want
me to shortly yes please Sense on that
what I believe is to be true is that
it's a distortion uh if a man wants to
be anything else than attracted to a
woman and vice versa because it weakens
you it's those corrupt entities that do
that it's not the real self because it
weakens you how can something that
weakens you be of benefit to you and the
planet it shouldn't be that way if you
look at at men who are not embodying
masculine energy but are embodying
feminine energy so this is what I've
seen two homosexuals are not the same
the one is just in his masculine and the
other is in his feminine and the one
who's in his feminine is
weakened he cannot
serve because he's weak he's not in his
he's not embodying his power the same is
with a woman who is a masculine who's
like queer she's more neutral so she's
not sexual she's not sensual so she
cannot be that
charging charging love for the masculine
because he's just not attracted to her
so who's going to cultivate passionate
Sexual Energy if there is not enough
polarity and attraction so this is why
God created women beautiful if they take
care of themselves and not burn
themselves out and not uh repress their
sexual energy and also not exploit their
energy they become beautiful because
every woman is beautiful it's a
distortion to be ugly it's a distortion
to be fat because you're you're you're
just not living up your to to your
highest self that's why you don't want
to move or you don't want to take care
of yourself we should all God loves
Beauty if you look around yourself all
there is is beauty so God loves people
to be beautiful as in strong and in
their own Natural Essence so if a woman
is not attractive for her partner he
will also not be interested in being
with her in a union because then he's
like investing money energy and time and
someone that's not even sexual and
sensual so there's not going to be any
sexual energy cultivated so why would he
invest in that he just doesn't see
that's why a man wants an attractive
woman because he knows where he's
investing in and it's a good thing to
want a beautiful woman and attractive
woman because when you're investing in
her you know that the sexual energy that
will be cultivated there will go all in
in in the purpose of new Earth God
Paradise yes and all energy that is uh
that is leaked into from porn and and to
uh t and pleasure that's all an
investment into hell into reality of
survival like you can see it in this way
God gives you every day thousand EUR
where do you invest it in because your
life force energy is even more prior
your money like with your Sexual Energy
you in you manifest money that's why you
see people who who repress anger and
Sexual Energy usually also harder time
to really become wealthy because you
need to be like dang a little like this
to become more wealthy yeah so a woman
also attracts a more wealthy man when
she is in her feminine Radiance and and
doesn't repress her Sexual Energy when
she she can show her beauty without like
being all too masculine or too repressed
or too weak in that so the strength of a
man is his power his strength
emotionally physically uh mentally his
his worship and the strength of a woman
is her sensuality yeah that's how they
polarize each other the most when you
look at the queer Community you can see
they're all equal they're all
neutralized there is no true passionate
sex there there is just like animalistic
play that is just weird and I have
nothing against those people because
those people are victims themselves to
those corrupt entities that convince
them that they're they are doing the
right thing but if they were doing the
right thing they would become more
stronger than they are but they're not
they're weakening and usually those
people all have mental problems and then
they project that onto their parents and
onto
Society but you you already have mental
problems before those entities uh
because those entities they love low
vibration people because they are easier
to influence and to uh corrupt yeah so
those beings they take weak people
that's why it's not allowed to Believe
In Fear except for fearing something
that lowers your vibration but scarcity
mind mindset victim Consciousness
mindset is not allowed because it lowers
your vibration and everything that
lowers your vibration takes you out of
your Center Point and then you just not
become a candidate for New Earth during
the Great Purge when we massively uh
like when more than half of the people
of this planet will stop having sex
prior
marriage there will be a vast shift in
the vibration of the planet already by
this conversation the vibration of the
planet will massively shift because I'm
absolutely convinced that many men that
hear me talk will be like yes she's
right why am I not with the troop why am
I why am I leaking all over the place
why am I leaking to [__] who only
want me for my money uh like on only
fans and on porn s sites you know why am
I leaking there my Lion energy why am I
and then and then all of that is is then
uh that the leaking is is not giving the
codes that come from the Union and
therefore it's not manifesting the
reality of the new world as quickly so
delete what do codes what do you mean
Cod codes I mean that when you get into
the Divine Union when there is the
sacred honor in the sexual then what
happens is there's an
intensifying of the of that polarity of
the of God relating with itself like the
godhead with itself in that sacred
container is a feedback loop on an on
ident identifying what is like the what
the sacred
creativity of of that gives yeah yeah
you become basically more conscious of
yourself through that constant polar de
uh constant charging of the polarization
that you get feedback through each other
and it literally HIDs your vibration
like nothing else exactly no meditation
no nothing yeah and it's and it's crazy
because some because it's not even
sexual it's just through the it's not
penetrative is what I'm saying it's just
that the honor in the sexual has been
sealed in that way and because of that
then all of these things start getting
like full body activations just with
yeah and and I mean it's better than
quote any uh other like Med meditation
psychedelic um that's danger chasing yes
yeah chasing sex or chasing a material
luxurious material
object those things are all like quote
like your quote
temporary high or whatever but there's
like I mean like an
orgasmic dance of God for like minute
minutes and hours and then days weeks
years because of the Divine Union and
then yeah so absolutely and there's
nothing more beautiful than that I mean
we came here for that isn't that the
highest thing that you meet your true
love and then you can also hug each
other and kiss each other and look each
other in the eye and tell each other I
love you isn't that like yes the thing
like look at the Sunset and sit in the
grass and just look at each other isn't
that like the thing yeah I mean if if we
start valuing that then we're all lost
and we are lost and and I've had so many
women that came in contact with my
content on Instagram that said I had a
calini Awakening the moment I decided
that I'm only available for the
one and they were like massively full of
energy and they didn't have that with
psychedelics and everything and I told
them I said psychedelics are opening
your ARA up to entities that can just
invade you and I've seen that also with
one enlightened person who frequently
takes psychedelic I'm not sure why he
does that he doesn't need it because
he's very
talented but I can I saw that he
sometimes uh would respond in Anger to
towards me uh like he was on an athetic
dance he was DJ there and then um after
that I wanted to ask him a few questions
and he was like Angry towards me and I
was really sincerely coming from a good
intention because I enjoyed the whole
evening I thought he did an amazing job
with the music and then he all of a
sudden acted angry towards me and then I
could see those were those entities
because they were feel threatened by my
energy field which happens very often
very often people start to like um Purge
quote unquote but they don't know that
because they they're projecting
something and they think they are that
but I don't believe in any evil from the
human being there is no evil God did not
create us evil God did not create us
um weak or insecure that is all an
attack and Corruption and a distortion
from those entities they they started to
attack us they turned away from the
light and started to attack us we are
pure the only thing that we need to
protect ourselves from is that force and
since that Force invaded human beings
suddenly we also have to protect
ourselves from certain human beings
because they're so unconscious and
they're so driven by their selfish
agenda which they're completely
identified with and then you have this
whole Matrix that makes one
worship the
ego and we're lost yeah majority of us
are lost yes the the Purity and
luminosity of God is Unstoppable and
unbelievable um and then there's this
the all the programs all of the programs
and
the
the the way that those programs spread
and the way that they like uh feedback
loop into each other and the way that
then like these little like quote from
that contraction then is seeking
oh and it's all about the dissolution of
those programs the satanic agendas and
programs and
then you find like what was never what
was never missing but was so apparently
distorted and going through
whatever um thing for you know God to
learn about itself experience itself for
it to for it to come back to itself
where it enters into the Union where it
enters into the union with itself in the
sacred container true love like dude I
love I love how much we all like
inherently know that true love is like
the Pinnacle human achievement like
embodied achievement is like true love
and then the way that true love feedb
feedbacks into this full bodied ecstasy
uh lived experience and the
manifestation of the new world the
ignition for that cuz you want to you
want to die for something that is
transcendent you want to die for
something that is completely selfless
completely that's the whole archetype of
Christ is is take yes just that in
itself is just so empowering especially
for the masculine to give itself fully
to that and it's so beautiful when it
comes in the Divine in the Divine Union
that there is that dying for that and
there's dying for transforming the
collective sins and building the new
world like if I ever hear men talking
about that you are immediately in the
new Earth Warrior Network and let's
[__] go baby let's [__] go yeah
let's go yes and you know what this
beautiful beautiful thing I want to
mention everyone who's watching right
now if you feel committed into becoming
a worrior to build new Earth because
that's the masculine responsibility we
women we cannot we can support you we
can offer our vision we can share our
share which are really important codes
to offer the vision in the nourishment
and the sharing we cannot build
everything that you see around you is
built by men this chair this table like
some Engineers some technical did that
like this camera this computer those
were not women so because we our brain
is wired differently do you think uh car
driving and stuff is harder for me in
arranging things because my brain
returned back to its original state that
it would more focused on love and flow
and receptivity and joy and lightness
and humor which are all feminine
qualities and within that I can offer my
share and compliment the masculine but I
can definitely not take on their role
and I don't want that even because to me
it's completely boring but what what men
do all day I can really not do that but
for them it's very interesting because
that's their purpose and for them it's
like boring to take pictures of
themselves and put them on Instagram
that's why you often see men who have
literally no profile picture no picture
at all and then they hang around with
that account on Instagram watching other
women who have like tons of selfies you
can see like
this you know men that don't have a role
on social media right but of course
when you have a role uh it's different
but it's just funny so uh in this I can
offer the masculine this because I
assume a lot of men watch your podcast
because you've been putting out quite
some masculine content and yeah also
about self-realization but I can say if
you recognize yourself as one of the
builders and and holders of the new
Earth in any
way feels joyful to you and is of your
purpose and you recognize me as a
sincere messenger who is telling you and
reminding you I'm not telling anything
new like let's be
honest just a reminding and pointing
towards that which is ancient and sacred
and true and loving and
free to remind them and tell them that
if you want to fulfill your mission on
this planet and you truly want to
realize your your trest nature whether
there is Enlightenment or not you know
uh doesn't even matter if you can
fulfill your purpose and serve God and
God only you've done your job whether
Enlightenment happens or not is not up
to you because maybe you have not lived
enough lives to to to to achieve that or
like to have that Liberation it's quite
possible but if you are a man of honor
and you honor God you protect the
feminine and you serve your mission you
did everything God expected
you you you did everything and you will
have a joyful life and you will have a
life and you will be respected woman and
I want to place this is so interesting
that even if uh quote you're uh not uh
seeing that there's quote no one home
even if that is not there let's say that
even as long as you're
polarized
towards God fully selflessly as much as
you can with your unique calling gift
blueprint in Divine Union with the
feminine and as long as that's there
that you're already way more quote on
the team than anyone anyone else even in
quote non-dual [__] tripping balls on
on emptiness and form are the same thing
bro or whatever like just we know that
we know know that now it's about this
planet you know people are dying people
are being shot we know that emptiness
isn't is fullness but take your ass out
of there and go to Gaza and tell them
that emptiness that everything is equal
that eating from the toilet is as pleas
as eating eating sushi buffets or steak
Inn tell them that it doesn't matter
that that go and watch limbs that are
being shot and and and then come there
with nality nality without the guidance
of the abrahamic uh lineage for the is
Godless recent times is just Godless
because there's a lack of love love
cannot be without Freedom when you give
people total freedom they become pigs
that's why you need love and that's why
damasc and The Feminine need to be with
each other because otherwise they cannot
function yeah they I cannot function
properly because I'm too like I I'm very
emotional if there is no masculine field
around me I'm like waves and
uncontrollable
like it's okay because I realize my true
nature I don't do crazy stuff but for
women that have not realized their true
nature they're doing crazy things I've
seen it they're doing very immature
things when a woman is very much in her
feminine energy she needs the protection
from the masculine like he doesn't even
maybe necessarily have to do or say
anything but just his energy grounds a
woman for me I often times don't feel
grounded I I have been listening to rap
music and stuff
because that was kind of yeah serving me
in a way of like this masculine energy
that I was missing in my life because I
literally don't have a brother or anyone
like that is here I'm usually just on my
own and that has helped me to some
extent but here I could see that when I
return back to my most Natural Essence
that I cannot live without a man if I'm
depolarized then I can because then I'm
like a woman and a man and pretend to be
strong but that's also not when I'm
going to feel Blissful and full of
ecstasy because I'm depolarized I'm
transgender I'm like a woman outside but
a man half man half woman Inside serving
the The Matrix and becoming a more work
slave Matrix slave also what I realized
I cannot do one-on-one sessions I cannot
commit to to hours of work during the
day without depolarizing myself because
it takes me out of the Flow State it
makes me because a woman she has to have
a lot of free time to do whatever she
she cannot have all these commitments
and appointments all the time that takes
you out of the feminine energy feminine
energy is flow is just doing whatever
your body like whatever arises in the
moment and feels most relevant and it
doesn't mean that I'm lazy not at all I
tons of things but it's all just coming
from feminine energy because nobody's
putting a burden on me that I have to
work eight hours a day I I literally
cannot do that anymore that's why I've
only committed to the Sunday meetings
and I do some sometimes a podcast and
then I share out of Joy on my Instagram
tons of things but that's just play for
me that's that's I do that whenever I
feel like doing that I don't have to do
that and that's why I want to be like
this Instagram
gangster who doesn't have too much
commitments that have to be like on
point and on time because even coming on
time is hard for me like I came one and
a half hour later on this podcast
because I cannot do all that
and when I was in Miami I was I did so
so stupid I bought something because I
really liked there was a clothing that I
really liked and I was like a child like
in this spontaneous child energy I was
like yeah I have to have it and I looked
on my on my credit card it's like a
prepaid credit credit card and I thought
like well if I buy this I can just like
put money on the credit card and it will
be there by tomorrow but then the
tomorrow was
Saturday and the transaction didn't come
so I was in Miami for three days with
very little money because I could only
like cash like 300 or something and I
had to pay for a new hotel which was
almost 200 a night or like even more 300
so I was like moneyless there and then I
realized yeah that's like a masculine
trade to think ahead and not make these
impulsive decisions if I would be there
with my partner he would say like hey we
don't have that money like uh we're
gonna pay for that later when we're
gonna make that transaction and then
we'll do it or he would put his money
there and say okay I'm gonna buy it for
you then it will be sold but since I was
there like a
child in a candy store I was there for
three days without money I had to
literally think like where I'm going to
eat and how much money is gonna be for
like I became like a
broie in this I realized that that's why
I didn't travel through America I
returned back home because um arranging
hotels and fixing things became I put I
had to put in so much effort for that
that I was like this is not worth it for
me a woman should not be traveling on
her own uh when she's in the Kingdom of
Heaven because she cannot do that so I
returned back home after one or two
weeks I don't know how long I was there
I think one week or
so that was my my and what I also
noticed is that reality didn't allow me
to go
clubbing I met people there and they
were like yeah we're going to go out and
you can join us and it was all nice and
I thought like well at least I'm gonna
have a dance in a club in Miami with
them but then they became all
sick and then one of them had this
Kundalini Awakening because she was
messaging me like I have so much energy
and so I tried to enter a club a few
times I love I love the whole thing on
on freedom and love
really so deep but let me can I finish
this go ahead go ahead then I went into
a club and I was just I just wanted to
dance a few songs I didn't want to like
be there all night I was by myself but
reality I don't know something always
would arise I tried it two three times
and then I had to walk out of it like I
was just not even allowed to spend there
more than one minute because the the the
vibration wasn't matching and one time I
was also tracing the there like Miami is
the city of
loot it's the city of loot it's where
where where the Antichrist is being
targed is where the Antichrist is
prevailing the seductive depolarized
energy that is on the money and
destroying sacred Sexual Energy and just
wasting it all into
nothingness and what I saw there is that
people are desperate in clubs they're
desperate they're they're drinking
alcohol because they don't have Joy by
themselves they cannot dance without
alcohol they cannot have a funny talk
without alcohol they're desperate they
they seduce each other then they go and
[__] each other and then the devil the
devil has what it needs it's it's you're
like a slave to the devil because it
through you it gets its dinner only
through you it cannot get sexual energy
from God because God doesn't give it we
give it we humans we are giving it and
the devil is like yeah yeah so that's
seductive the woman that seduces you
into anything outside of marriage prior
marriage she's the devil in beautiful
clothes and it's a smart devil because
it knows if the face is beautiful you're
gonna be
trapped unless unless you're sitting in
honor yes exactly unless you get
reminded and you get disgusted by these
woman who seduce you that is actually
what men should remind that that that
you the goddess is someone who will
never give herself to you prior marriage
because she fears God she fears lowering
her vibration she honors herself and all
women that reside in the Kingdom of
Heaven they are virgins and they are
afraid of having sex which is a very
rightful thing to fear because it it
will get you cast out of the reality of
creation so why would you not fear
that unless it's post marriage with the
intention of children that kind of whole
doesn't have to be with the intention of
children uh if there is enough polarity
sex will arise like naturally already
because there is charge and there is a
walking towards the marriage which
usually takes up a few months so people
are already like celibate and they're
already like when do we see each other
when we gonna have the first kiss so
that's already happening but people
don't even have to have children or plan
on having children it's like in the
Kingdom of Heaven you decide whether you
want that or not and you consciously
manifest a child because a soul wants to
go through you um but in the reality of
survival when people are not fully
realized they they they have to use
something if if they want don't want to
have a child or maybe later on but you
see I I feel about children is like a
free choice if you want that it's good
if you don't want it it's also fine like
I I myself don't plan on having children
but I'm also not saying like it will
never happen but
because I already have a daughter and I
already experienced what that is like
and right and I feel that I can offer my
my insights in a different way to serve
Humanity because of that yes yes yes and
because of that of course but I do truly
truly see my my my role also in this
mothering energy because I have been
calling women on on in my stories out
and saying [__] to them which let's be
honest who else than your mother would
tell you when she wants to protect you
stop being a [__] no one else would do
that only your mother will love you so
fearlessly to pull you by your hair and
tell you stop being a [__] because she
knows that's how she can get through You
by hurting you is like drawing attention
the Quran and the Bible are also full of
very wrathful comments because that's
how caught the attention and it worked
because many men woke up to that because
they were like whoa Nargis is calling
someone [__] there must be something
behind it she's angry and we should get
angry when the honor of God is being
betrayed and when I see those corrupt
entities taking her away from from the
light because she is a sincere woman
she's a very loving woman a very
beautiful woman and a very feminine
woman but those curbed entities they
want to influence women she's naive and
young so I will not uh bash her but I
had to warn her because I love her and
she knows that and she she she has sent
me a beautiful song because she knows
that I love her she knows that I don't
hate her I don't hate anyone but if
someone dishonors God I will show my
hate because it's hateful you hate God
when you do that so I'm going to mirror
that hate back to you and I'm allowed to
do that because I'm selfless I'm not
doing that from selfish reasons I'm
selfish when I am not calling her out
and seeing that she's doing wrong things
that's selfish because then I want to
keep her me this this is pretty
interesting CU it also relates with the
masculine in the way of um if the
masculine is repressing um calling
itself out for uh being dishonorable
basically so if you're repressing it and
not calling out dishonor then you're not
actually allowing the god flow you're
restrict you're restricting it and so
for the for the masculine to be fully
released and ful ful flowing it's going
to sometimes um come off like uh Angry a
it's going to come off angry with
discipline about honor and about uh
Christ and about really dying fully into
um into into truth and at a at a level
that you're asking for the reflection
for um yeah yeah so so I there's there's
there's resonance there there's always
going to be Grace there's always got to
be Elegance that's contined to be
refined and imp and improved on of
course CU it's all about the Catalyst
actually Landing itself um so there's
that you as a man have the authority to
call out your brothers when you see
their
cowardness and lack of authenticity you
can tell them like men up because you
recognize them being weak or insecure
but I don't necessarily recognize men
because they're not as close to me as a
woman is like when I see a woman doing
dumb things I immediately know where
she's coming from because I'm a woman
too I know how women think and how they
act and what their intentions are but
with men I'm not as accurate because
they're just more of a like a different
species to me you know I'm just I don't
I don't have masculine friends whatever
I don't know how they are but you know
that so you can you should you should
call men out when you see your brothers
uh weakening themselves and tell them
like men up because you can you can
reflect that to them and I can reflect
that to my women and I will do that to
them I will fulfill that role for my
women and and tell them but you know
this is saddening to me is that many
spiritual women that have been following
me from my non jeel content and about
self-realization and Enlightenment when
I was neutralizing my appearance because
I was afraid to show my sensual energy
because I thought nobody's going to make
think I'm serious or nobody's going to
think I am self-realized because let's
be honest who puts on red lipstick and
it's going to dance on Instagram and
talk about Enlightenment it's like a bit
of like strange
combination I thought so I had a lot of
followers and then when I started to
dance on Instagram and write poetry
about sex and love and freedom uh and
honor so many people followed me because
they just were shocked that a woman who
talks about
Enlightenment dances and shows her
sensuality in a way that is just not
[__] but it is
feminine through that I could see that
we are so depolarized that whenever we
see true feminine energy we immediately
think it's it's wrong it's [__] or
whatever but at the same time those
people who have unfollowed me I know
what they do on the weekends they have
sex with people on athetic dance
festivals and pretend to be Seekers of
light but because they repress their
sexual energy they were clearly
triggered by me showing uh my my face on
Instagram in a certain way that's their
Shadow I Express that on Instagram but
I'm celibate but they are having sex on
festivals but when they see me
expressing Sexual Energy they're like
whoa that's weird man and follow Man
follow that button so that is the
Distortion that women who are seeking
light don't recognize me as a real
person who's authentic and who's home
they don't accept me and with men you
have that too and they're the ones that
do that tell you immediately that
they're now honorably awaiting their
Divine Union and then they have their
crazy energetic kundalinis and whatnot
and that's yeah and and same same thing
with men I love this too same thing with
men about staying steadfast in the in
the uh in the Sexual Energy being
honorable is that's that's where New
Earth will will come from cuz I I see
the leakage is going nuts it's all over
the place I mean it's everything from
the the top down global elitist
pedophilia um all the way to um there's
also perversions in in spiritual
communities you were talking about
ecstatic festivals spiritual communities
and and their perversions with um with
dishonorable sexual energies and
especially in the relationship between
the the quote teacher and the quote sing
student there's lots and lots of
distortions there that are also to be uh
refined
yes absolutely absolutely and you know
what I've seen with my own eyes I've
been to athetic Festival dance here in
Holland the cleared to be cleared
actually at a collective level this is
something that I that I wanted to to
also talk about is that um there's a
clearing that is happening on a
collective level of the idea of of
ruling ruling or ownership the world
economic Forum Global elitist are all
about ruling and ownership and control
they're control archs control archs okay
yeah like oligarch meets control control
oligarchy okay now but the fascinating
thing is that we still haven't fully
gotten out of that Paradigm even in
spirituality because in spirituality
there is still a control Ary there is
still there's still the desire for
ownership
over people ruling over people and I
know this is something that I you know I
reflected to and I'm curious to hear
what you what your take is on it but
that why why do you talk about ruling in
the new world why like from a
centralized perspective it seems like
where you're coming from yeah is that
you're coming from a centralized place
that miam and Ben are to be rulers of
the world in a centralized way and what
was reflected back is why not where's
that coming from first and second is why
not see it as a distributed network of
equal new Earth Warriors working
together as a round table of igniting
new Earth yes yes
yes
um I don't know what you mean what who
are you referring to
well our our well I've seen in your
stories that you're that you're talking
about um basically the basically the
Messiah the Messiah kind of like the
centralized spiritual Messiah is
equivalent to a centralized World
economic Forum or Global Elites it's no
different one is economic and political
Global Elite control oligarchy and the
other one is a quote uh spiritual
Messiah controlled uh oligarchy control
oligarchy okay versus the new Earth
which is a decentralized network of new
Earth Warriors that are equals because
they've all went through the process of
integrating emptiness into love
themselves and then they work as a
Roundtable yes yes it's
true there is a
decentralization yet there will be new
laws new
Earth that will be sourced by the one
who is the return of the
Christ so Christ left was taken by God
he was not he was not so they hang
someone else the whole story that Christ
was hanged that's corrupt God took him
and they hanged someone else but why do
you think that the new quote laws which
are like natural or Cosmic laws of like
what a new Earth is what what makes you
think that those laws come from a
centralized Place why would why would
those laws emerge from just like biology
I mean we're just replicating biology by
do the internet and then we're
replicating the Internet by doing a
singularity called Consciousness being
new Earth yes so this is the importance
uh guidance from God the the the
scriptures were actually usually
initially meant to form for guidance for
people so they will not become pigs we
were all pigs prior go Prophet Muhammad
prior uh Christ because that's why those
Messengers were were were
sent to guide us they were already from
a very high they were like aliens to the
other people they were sent to guide
people to God because many people
they're not in a hidden State of
Consciousness so they need someone else
to point them towards that so the new
Earth will have a different law law that
is not based on Greed ego and capitalism
and and and and scarcity the new and
protection and fear and victim conscious
the new law will be sourced by the one
who is the return of Christ and Christ
what makes what makes you think that the
quote return of Christ is not a
decentralized network of equal new Earth
Warriors what makes I tell go ahead I
will tell you I will tell you uh um
everything is a biological energetic
emergence go ahead
the and by the way Christ Christ wasn't
the only place that quote the hammer
struck you know there have been Hammer
strikings many times to put things into
the new Earth frequency absolutely we
are moving to New Earth from the
beginning but things are getting tight
now and it has been uh uh speculated by
the prophet Muhammad very very very uh
evidently when people are interested in
it search for Antichrist Dalal uh day of
Judgment Day of reckon um PR on Earth I
mean the Antichrist is basically
anything that's just not Christ it's
it's that is a depolarized feminine
energy that's Eve that's Antichrist that
is Eve it's a very specific energy it's
not just everything it's it's that which
which which initially harms us and
depolarizes us because the attack of the
corrupt Army is to the weaken Us and how
can you weaken us is by depolarizing us
making us weak because when we are weak
we don't feel attracted towards each
other I mean I don't feel attracted to a
weak there are also plenty of unions
that are happening but from a place of
control Agy also so anyway they're
they're just to keep that going in there
there is no sacred passionate sex there
and that's the the the attack of the
corrupt Army is to take away sex from
the planet the attack is on sex is on
Godly sex because Godly sex is strength
confidence power and on there so those
evil corrupt entities they want to steal
us from our sex Sexual Energy so they
can use it for their evil agenda and
they have been doing that that's why
we're like pigs now on the planet I mean
a lot of people suffer even the wealthy
countries their pockets are fulfilled
but people are binging on sleeping pills
they have depressions they're lost they
have a beautiful house beautiful wife
but they go watch porn or rent some only
fans chick for sex seemingly and then
cry on her face telling her that they're
so sad and lonely okay we're still
talking about those Antichrist pattern
so yeah answering the question why the
why the centralized desire for for
ownership there no desire it's a command
of God nobody in this human a a a
command for for centralized Spiritual
Authority yes God has promised us that
Christ will return and everyone knows
this is and God has promised that that
that game that game has been played many
many times many many times and it and it
keeps getting you talk about it all the
time with Osho we all talk about it all
the time we're not repeating that
pattern it's not going to happen it's
not gonna happen I I don't care what
what what uh people assume I'm just here
to share my point of view and there will
be a part of the people that watching
this podcast who will be like hey that's
interesting let me look into that and
research this like this woman is saying
something that's can be quite
interesting and there will be a part
that will say does nonsense because it
doesn't fit into my a world viiew of
what is well the universe is
decentralized it's a singularity but
it's decentralized there will be an
authority and that will be the one who
is the return of Christ and Christ was
taken please let me finish I only finish
you go ahead go ahead so God uh the the
Messiah was returned to God when he was
33 he will as in spirit return back into
a body of a man here on the planet who
will then have the authority and then
have the responsibility to Source new
laws for sincere people to protect them
from dishonoring themselves and
weakening themselves those laws as in
guidance will serve as guidance for
women and men that are sincere who want
to live in New Earth reality want to
protect their vibration because your
vibration will be your only path to
enter new Earth reality and not be wiped
Away by the Great Purge when the planet
is going to when we collectively stop
having sex outside of honor the the um
energy the life force the the vibration
of the planet will heighten and everyone
who's below that will start to purge
many of those people will die because
they simply get so sick some some people
will survive it because sickness uh uh
makes you stronger agreed can I just
keep us on the exact point of discussion
though so where you where you uh think
that the the quote new Earth codes come
through a single point what is being
said here is that the new Earth codes
come through vessels that are already
empty and in love and then they're
reflected to each other to further
refine them into yeah yeah so that's
that's just what's being said so so
there there will be there will laws will
be sourced and of Guidance just to for
people to to get inspired and guided to
protect themselves the the laws of
guidance are for people who are not
enlightened because those people are not
protected from these corrupt entities
they can constantly be get controlled by
their ego that's why religion was never
meant to be a religion it was only meant
there to to guide guide people into
Enlightenment and into and whilst
they're walking towards Enlightenment
that they don't fall prey to those
corrupt entities out of ignorance that's
why this whole Osho thing completely
failed and he got killed that was his
karma because he didn't protect Sexual
Energy he released it he liberated it
but he didn't protect it that's why he
got killed it's his karma because that
depolarized woman that was there that
she Sheila was Antichrist who lied about
him on Netflix that he was taking drugs
while she drugged him and she killed him
those that whole thing played out
because because of not protecting the
honor of God but just telling that
everything is all Freedom no he had to
get him manifest himself a woman who
will tell him I'm not going to have sex
with you outside of honor and first make
him in love with her so he would
actually want to turn into a good guy
for her but unfortunately he didn't meet
her her and he couldn't serve as that
example and what you look at the whole
Osho crew if you go to Osho Center
they're all weak people they're not
strong people they're all weak
depolarized because they're they're just
they're just like all of love all of
compassion let's just have sex and not
commit like weak people right i' I've
been in that Center once because I
thought like I'm just interesting what's
going on in the Usher Center a few years
ago those were all butterflies there I
didn't meet any that's happening that's
happening in many spirit communi so
basically that entire Paradigm itself is
being cleared it's not just Miami right
it's actually in the spiritual Paradigm
too and all of that is being cleared
yeah but in Miami there were no there
were strong people but those strong
people were just serving a very
materialistic agenda which is a
completely other spectrum of the extreme
is like the complete materialism and
then you have ooso which is like oh all
this love and light and let's just fly
around like butterflies and we are
bringing those into balance like no I
can love stuff and buy myself jewelry
and things and not think like oh that's
not spiritual and at the same time I can
serve God and God only that is what we
came here to be and there will be an
authority only for the sincere not for
the arrogant and the self-righteous
people that think they're enlightened
prior Enlightenment the ones that are
enlightened when they see the authority
they will get the transmission and they
will know exactly how to fulfill their
unique purpose because people who are
enlightened they don't need any
Authority they don't need any guidance
because they cannot fall out of
alignment when enlightened people are
not having sex outside of Honor they are
not cast out of the Kingdom of Heaven
they don't need any Authority who tells
them what to do or not to do because
they're already only serving God every
second of the day they are serving God
but the people that are still like is
this my ego is this not my ego should I
have sex now should I not have it should
I chase this man should I not gu they
they need an authority and that
Authority will tell you trust me
unconditionally because I've emptied
myself I will never betray you because I
pledged allegiance to God and God only
please trust me please don't doubt me if
I mirror your [__] back to you please be
humble and this is also my anger towards
the few people that have betrayed me
it's like I'm for free on Instagram I
don't earn money there I forget to eat I
forget to sleep and then I put an effort
to explain things to you to protect you
I don't get anything from you and then
you betray me you talk about me behind
my back and you doubt my my sincerity
and then you reflect to me that I am
arrogant people who come to me with
inferior energy I cannot act other than
to trigger that by telling them
something that sounds arrogant it's just
the mirroring effect it's just a
mirroring effect that comment that she
made like hey how is your feminine
energy feeling today that was a pleasing
energy because before that I gave her
reflection that made her feel inferior
so then she she was felt weak towards me
so then she came I'll just I'll just say
this cuz I don't I don't have the
context that you're talking about
exactly but but but but but the other
but the other thing about this is that
it feels like this is some of the things
that we'll need to do roundtables about
to get to exactly the things that are
being discussed because that's that's
that's the way to get that's the way to
get to these clearances that's the way
to get to these these harmonies in this
in this web it's simple she she has to
either unfollow me and never talk to me
or she has to unconditionally trust me
there's no in between because if she's
going to hang in between she's going to
betray me and gossip about me with other
woke men and some of them were
enlightened and she was posting all
those print screens from from various
teachers which is a betraying energy
because she has to come to me with that
instead of uh gossiping about me because
I've well it's commit it's committing to
the the the Divine Union it's committing
to sexual honor and that's what you mean
by he was not committed to that yes yes
yes but yes yes yes yes but that's
that's what's
happening is that and through the
reflections that's what's happening it's
through the reflections that's what's
happening
and that that's sort of the test the
test is committing to sexual honor
committing to Divine Union committing to
that and then from that place is this
network this network of new Earth from
that place though from that place and
it's and it's from a place of of
sometimes there will be anger in what is
said because it's the discipline in Inc
correcting but it's also elegant and
it's graceful and it's and it's and it's
to nourish n it's to nourish the whole
and it it is interesting how that
specific that specific thing um about
where where quote I mean you've probably
heard many times but people have been
people have been talking about quote the
emergence of what is like a network of
Buddhas or christs or whatever you want
to call it that that that that is and I
mean it's so beautiful cuz that's like
the natural frequency of the universe
itself it is that it's kind of harmonic
it's that kind of harmonic and
purification that kind of harmonic and
purification the people who come to me
with the with with a sincere intention
they will not get anything crazy from me
because I don't I'm a mirror I will
reflect exactly that back and that's
Harmony When come someone comes from
Harmony to me they get reflected back
Harmony but she came to me with a
pleasing energy so then I responded
saying oh yeah that's how that's how I
like it with my feminine decent
disciples or something it's a joke it's
not real I don't mean that but I just
was a reflection and it triggered her so
it did it it served its purpose it
triggered her because she felt triggered
in her inferiority I don't feel inferior
to anyone if the king of Holland comes
to me or the queen and they start
talking to me I feel completely equal to
just to be completely transparent you're
you're speaking of Nikki Nicole Ortega
yes yeah okay and then now also um
there's some sort of mediation that is
being requested or reconciliation that's
being requested forgave her
something yeah and and this is and this
is something more for like Roundtable
and whatnot and so to actually yeah it's
not even about her we didn't even have
to mention her name because she was not
doing anything crazy or something you
know it's a good it's a good it's a good
example though because we live we live
in a social memory complex now right we
live in the new Earth frequency now
right because of that we have to live in
true transparency there's no other way
so now as we live in true transparency
it's important for us to know how to be
in that true transparent reflective
purifying space together together yes
and within that within that Oneness
there is people who who have lived Many
Many Lives who have been scrubbing
toilets in various lives and earned
their mark s and who are sent to this
planet to have realized their true
nature at a very young age and they are
assigned to offer protection to the ones
that are younger in Soul and that need
that are here for their purpose to
integrate lessons but also require
protection from a wing from people that
are here to mirror you when you are
doing something out of proportion fair
fair enough fair enough but just but
just to be clear again what's happening
is quote a hierarchy is being formed
based on something that is an quote
older Soul versus a younger Soul just to
be
clear but but ju but just to be clear
what's being said is that within that
distributed Network there will always be
some sort of
transformational communications and fair
and Electro electromagnetism that is
then always springing up what is the new
so I mean there there there may be there
may just be there may just be for
example someone might want K CLA Schwab
to rule their life because CLA Schwab is
an old soul and CLA Schwab knows how to
make the best
civilization okay so the same thing's
true you know if the new Earth Warrior
network is World economic form it's just
sing on CLA Schwab right there's no
difference at all between quote the new
Earth Warrior Network than sing on uh
maram or whoever as the quote who's
coming to to be the quote ruler or
leader there's just it's it won't work
it'll never work it'll always produce
the same centralized hierarchies it will
always do it it's a lesson that is only
can only be felt by full
universalization a universalization is a
distributed that's why all of these web
3 Technologies are emerging beyond the
internet because everybody wants to live
in a decentralized web just like nature
nobody nobody wants to hear a source of
a Authority tell them uh especially when
they're let's say when they finally feel
like they're empty and they're in love
there's it's only equality it's only
equality at that
point yes in the polarity there cannot
be is not the same as a selfish person
there's no equality the the person who's
the return of Christ is higher than
everyone and he's the only Authority
that an authority over me and everyone
who has not realized their true nature
and is not fully enlightened and not not
fully in the Kingdom of Heaven is not an
equal to me because I destroyed myself
completely I lost everything and
everyone for God and I have the right to
talk about this because I did that and
my reward is that I am in Bliss I am
Bliss I am Ananda itself and I will
speak up about it because this is unjust
you're not gonna tell a lion you can
tell a lion that he's not going to be an
authority satanic programs will be they
will be purified and cleared that's why
when I wrote to you I said that if it's
clear that someone is still selfing and
they're asking for your reflection then
it's organic to take a place of
authority and discipline and reflection
it's absolutely organic no I have the a
place of authority at all times I will
not only take that place you have to
listen you have to listen to what I'm
going to share right now this is
important it will work because it's a
command of God I'm not talking I'm not
doing anything I didn't buy that Crown
out of egoic pleasure I have the command
of authority at all times you think
that's going to work I would never I
don't care what's going to work because
I don't care about the future what is
truly real for me is this very moment if
you think about what's going to work
you're already too much in future I'm
not there yet I'm just saying what needs
to be said right here right now and
that's all you get and that's all I have
because I don't know anything but what I
feel is to be true is that a a selfish
person can humble itself and learn and
take guidance from people who are not
selfish and humble themselves in that
and all the enlightened people who will
recognize the authority of someone who's
completely selfish and has the right
just like Prophet Muhammad got a bigger
assignment than some other person just
like the Christ had a bigger assignment
than another person those enlightened
people who are not uh hurt hurt or
weakened or wounded by the inferiority
complex they will recognize the return
of Christ and they will tell them I am
loyal to you and they themselves will
serve as a pointer of light in their
country who will enable other people
to ignite their light and within that we
are like light bulbs who are igniting
each other but there will be an
authority and there will be and you
don't and and you have to understand
that someone who is completely selfless
Ely there won't be and that's why in the
comments there's written would love for
Nar would love for naris to surrender to
what to Atlas is saying because there's
a Contin there's a continued uh like
desire for ownership coming out of that
mouthpiece this is a reflection of the
Shadow government of the Shadow
spiritual Paradigm the God has promised
what arises will be a distributed
Network it will be it will be a
distributed network of new denying any
distributed network of course the I Am
All Pro Bitcoin and decentralization of
money and everything I I can I assure
you that all wealth will be returned to
source and to selfless people who will
distribute it in all equality and at
some point we in New Earth will not work
for money you will not work for money
you will work because you [__] enjoy
working yeah but you're still missing
the reflection the reflection is
specifically about the oblit about the
obliteration of Shadow governments and
Shadow spirituality has s it's an
attachment to the shadow of hierarchy
and spirituality AB absolutely not
you're speaking from your own truth
because you have a shadow on Authority
God is distributed inferior you you feel
inferior I don't feel inferior God has
always been distributed he'll never be
centralized moving forward here why why
did God send Jesus to to mankind why did
God send Prophet Muhammad were they the
same than other people because because
there were multiple again it it emerged
just like a biological Network do you
see how
that will also emerge and that person
will not be playing a boss over offer
you love exactly exactly
exactly that's what this and that's what
this is just like just like what we're
doing right now there's just no
Authority here right it's just
Consciousness with itself from a place
of equality because there's already been
enough emptying and enough love to be
able to see that this
is this is that distrib yeah yeah but
we're not about everyone slow on slow on
slow on we're not talking about everyone
let's put that to the side for a second
okay there will be the clearing of those
programs wait wa wait wait relax relax
relax relax relax there relax relax
relax relax we just just try try try try
a little bit try I'm a so so now so now
so now from from this place from this
place there are those satanic programs
that are being cleared right but then
there's this quote what we're calling
this new Earth Warrior Network the
emergence of that from an equality of
emptiness and love and that's exactly
like what this appears like like this
conversation itself Consciousness having
this conversation there's a very strong
uh attachment that I'm feeling there to
hierarchical nature of spirituality but
you know that's just what it is person
is not the same as a not enlightened
person period because one has emptied
themselves from identification with ego
and the other has not and the other is
arrogant by think
that it knows better but you're still
missing it you're still missing it we're
not talking we're not talking about the
quote normal world anymore we're talking
about this we're talking about us we're
talking about us you and I having this
conversation right now okay coming from
a place of equality and not hierarchy
that is all that is being
said yeah but I'm not going to listen to
your advice well but that's you're going
to listen to my advice because I'm yeah
but you you just positioned yourself in
a hierarchy again you don't get it you
don't get it but that's okay I
positioned myself in love because I love
you I truly love you that's the only why
way why I can tell you the truth because
many people come to me with their soal
reflection to that I will not surrender
there's only one person in this world
that I will surrender to because he has
that Authority and the rest has to
purify it's not being surrendered to the
sexual it's not what's being said it's
about it's about it's not about that
it's about this it's about equal
recognizing what equality is in the
nature of consious equality go to the
Animal Kingdom go to the anal Kingdom
the one who's the strongest and the
biggest is the authority of all the
other animals that's how nature intended
it that's how order balance and Harmony
is integrated and how it's being
nurtured in the human you don't see what
is being said shadow of spirituality is
hierarchy there is no shadow of
spirituality especially in the my world
I don't I don't own that shadow I can
see that someone who embodies more
sexual energy than the other is an
authority because I don't follow anyone
on Instagram why because I have what I
need to know because I'm Connected To
Source
directly but but people on Instagram are
following me why because I'm authority
over them because I have more liberation
of sexual energy and therefore more
wisdom and more love to share and there
is nothing shameful about that
absolutely
absolutely I've tried I've
tried I've tried saying it a bunch of
times I'll try just one more one more
time I'll try I'll try I will never
agree on what you suggest me to do
because it's not it's not a suggestion
to do anything this is not what it is
it's not a suggestion to do anything
this we have we have a dog here right
the dog's name is teacup right yeah the
the dog just came over through the
window and was you
know it's the natural state of God pure
empty free already there right humans go
through their contraction and then their
expansion and then we quote say that yes
there are certain more purified more
empty more loving ones that kind of
thing okay now all that's being said all
that's being said and there's absolutely
no need for it to be received or
accepted or anything just all that's
being said is that the future of new
Earth is where those empty loving beings
come together in harmony to actualize
the mission and it is no longer a
centralized like World economic Forum
Shadow hierarchy in government or a
centralized spiritual hierarchy in
government and so that's just all that's
being reflected and it's interesting see
got to agree with with Atlas here in the
comments it just seems like there's a
distributed there and there's not here
there will that is that is the shadow
aspect of inferiority being triggered by
by the seemingly fear of Oppression and
Authority that's the shadow but if there
is a pair that is handing out guidance
to inspire you and protect you to
transition safely into new Earth because
they are the field of new Earth I
already live in New Earth I don't have
that suffering what a lot of people have
I'm just here for love I have new Earth
for me Paradise is the only real state
for me abundance is real I don't work
for money I just work one and a half
hour I committed myself in a week I
don't need anything from this world I
don't even I don't I just even forget to
sleep and eat I don't need anything from
this world I'm not selfish I'm not
oppressive I'm not here to portray
myself as someone who's better to get
attention or likes or money I don't get
anything from anyone and I don't need it
people have to recognize that I'm coming
from love I'm not from some selfish
hierarchy you are against hierarchy and
Authority because it has been oppressing
you because it was egoic if you have met
Christ when he was here on the planet
you would kiss his feet because you
would feel that's pure love no because
I'm no because I'm done no because I'm
done that's the difference that's the
difference done is done and then you
build the new Earth together in unison
without hierarchy and story
here yeah yeah for me the story is not
ended it has just started because we
have just actually ignited a very very
strong force into the O operation of
Enlightenment and it's is not a
discussion point because you are a
warrior of new Earth you are a warrier
of new Earth it's just that you uh have
been harmed and you have been wounded
just like another guy that I know that
left the wing because there has been an
inferior Shadow aspect that has not
fully been resolved and I'm here to
assure you that no one is in Authority
above you because you are God yourself
absolutely nobody is going to tell you
what to do or what not to do you are the
warrior of new Earth and you are being
fully respected in everything that you
are but you have to understand that
there is a wisdom in the animal kingdom
that is there that some people who are
stronger they are being learned from and
they have more rights than people who
are weak
and in the human society too you don't
go to someone who's poor to ask for
financial advice you go to someone who's
[__] rich and you ask them for advice
that's how it works so if you want to
realize Paradise for yourself on Earth
you go to someone who's already dead
that's why you're inviting me on this
podcast because I am new Earth you want
to talk to me about new Earth and about
Divine Union because I am that so what's
wrong with authority it's just it's just
a mirror that is handing you stuff from
love not not that there's anything not
that there's anything wrong again with
it when it comes to just the normal way
of contraction seeking expansion nothing
wrong with it there but when expansion
at its maximum comes together there's no
hierarchy absolutely and when you are
enlightened I don't I have anything to
to say to you anymore in regards to that
because then you are we just going to be
still just like a certain someone is
still towards me because we don't have
anything to exchange because we are both
already home so as long as that has not
been happening I tell people be sincere
and humble yourself be loyal because I'm
here for you if you don't recognize me
unfollow me but stop thring me like stop
thring and and and and uh convincing
other people of your arrogance because I
cannot serve you if you're not truly
loyal to me because there in that
disregard of loyalness you're are still
hiding your Shadow aspects of
inferiority and your uh uh resentment
towards Authority but Authority can only
harm you when you place yourself into a
victim State Consciousness when I I have
to share there's many people who want to
realize their true nature that are
watching this podcast you have to
understand my method before I realize my
true nature I saw a Dutch advit teacher
I saw all his sad songs on YouTube I
binged everything then I saw that he did
a sad sang I went to that satang I drove
all the way on the other side of the
Holland I told him I don't know [__]
you're enlightened I'm not enlightened
I'm don't know [__] I'm stupid I follow
my ego but I want what you have you're
free you're free I want that please
destroy all that is false and I asked I
went two or three times I went to that
satang it's like a whole weekend and
then I stayed in like some kind of like
Chalet that I rented there and then I
just kept on firing my questions but I
had like this complete openness to him
as an
authority and just those few me things
and we also had like one-on-one Zoom
sessions he just reflected that because
I was he never asked me for loyalty he
never asked me to surrender he never
said those things I was smart enough
myself that's why my Liberation happened
within one year from Kundalini Awakening
uh until the full uh opening up was one
year why because I was not arrogant I
was humble I didn't care that he was I
saw him as an authority and it worked
for me it worked for me I didn't see
myself as an inferior uh being towards
him I saw myself as someone who's like
uh blind so I was like if I trust you if
I trust your eyes eventually I will see
too and it happened like that and this
is a big mistake of a lot of people that
are hiding their arrogance on the
internet they don't go to a a guru and
just offer themselves completely in
their unconditional
trust and let them destroy be destroyed
instead they watch this Guru this Guru
this Guru but they never truly surrender
to one you don't even have to be
physically there with that Guru you just
have in yourself you have to like fully
surrender yourself to truth
so then they Place comment this is this
is this they know everything about all
these gurus they have read all these
books they don't know they know
everything about spirituality they know
more than I know they've read more than
I've read but they didn't get it they
didn't get it that you have to
completely think of yourself as the most
stupid person on
Earth yeah order to your
ego you see that's that's the shadow I
got it I got it I got it bang blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
that's it that's it yes I got you
damn eventually where where's that
where's that coming from the lius the
lus that was just that was just speaking
to how nonsense is an important way to
recognize what one is that's all that
was so where was that coming
from so what what was coming from where
the
gotcha you see the shadow in you got
triggered it came to the service that's
why you made those very weird was just
nonsense that's all it was nonsense is
an instrumental part in obliterating
conceptualization which is crucial to
recognize what one is but anyway it's
just we're we're it's it's okay it's
okay that you know this is our first
this is our first conversation after two
years I'm a woman I have the same brain
as you have so I don't fully understand
everything saying it's okay but I made
my point and you made your point and I
truly enjoyed this conversation because
me too really yeah we really got down
yeah we did we did yeah we
did we got yeah yeah I agree I agree yes
yes yes and this is and this is the this
is that thing of like you know you meet
each other as equals and you can still
play and laugh and be joyful and be free
exactly yes it's so it's so beautiful
like cuz there was so much juice in the
in the podcast on all of the subjects
and it's great we
got I love it I love it men are boring
women are
fun it's it's so so fun only talk about
concepts with women we hold the
[Laughter]
energy like I loved when when we dove
into Divine unions and the way that they
ignite the mission and the purity of
them like that's so rich and I mean we
covered basically everything that we
wanted to talk about and it feels like
moving forward we'll you know we'll keep
playing we'll maybe have more round taes
like this which will be exciting and
yeah yeah yeah let's go let's go let's
go yeah yeah remember when we danced
when we were at the monastery and then I
don't know did we dance after or before
we put on I think after put on music
right right right right the Pod yeah
yeah yeah it was either before after the
Pod yeah yeah yeah yeah I could put on
some music now to like celebrate the
moment of um well but but wait but wait
because the the pods get demonetized if
it's not uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly yeah in New Earth that will
not
exactly celebrate with music and
nobody's gonna care about royalties and
money and earning two cents for their
selfish oh my God that's so like well
that's what kind that's what Kanye's uh
really passionate about you can tell
Kanye had God energy flowing flowing
through him because what happened was he
bur he burst out of the music industry
and the Hollywood area saying that all
of that is centralized corrupted
hierarchies artists don't get [__] we
need new contracts where artists get
ownership and bigger royalties and all
that kind of stuff and then oh my gosh
that created the you know that's the
juicy gemstone of what yay was erupting
as and I love love him for that hugely
for that Pro that like if you talk about
decentralization and you're referring to
that you have all my that is exactly
what I'm to Anarchy exactly Anarchy is
built on ego the Anarchy is built on ego
but what I believe in in New Earth if
there is going to be a king and a queen
they have to be fully inl enight ened
because if they are fully enlightened
they will be selflessly serving everyone
and they will never be harming anyone
but they have to be truly selfless you
see that is the importance and as long
as there is a centralization based on
ego it's not working but for Animals
it's working because they're not
arrogant not self-righteous and they
don't have an ego so that's why in
Animal Kingdom they're fighting but
things are still harmonized there they
have not made pics out of them M El they
remained animals we harmed them we
harmed animals but they themselves had
living a very good life because they
don't have an egoic hierarchy they have
an hierarchy that is fair the strongest
one is the boss period and with men and
women that is not with physical strength
because we're not animals it's with
Sexual Energy it's God Force so the more
enlightened you are the more of an
authority you are over other people the
more people will follow you that that's
how you see is the case you look at e
tole he has a lot of followers here's a
good way here's a good way to put it you
know you know you know when you go see a
a doctor for an ailment right you go see
a doctor for an ailment like if you need
a a crucial surgery right you want a
good surgeon right yeah you want a good
surgeon right so you go to a good
surgeon or if you want to learn the
violin you go to a really good
instructor right to teach you to teach
you the musical instrument right so in
terms of being on the path towards
dissolution of the separate self right
then you want those that are quote most
dissolved right then then when it is
dissolved that's where the equal that's
where the equality that's where the new
Earth Network that's where this type of
thing can happen yes yes and for sure we
need to work with each other together
like the the the inline people will
serve their group of people and the the
uh new Earth Warriors will serve their
purpose in building the new Earth we
need each other we need each other like
the king cannot be without his uh taxi
driver because then it will not get
anywhere so we need each other but we
have to also honor and respect each
other in each other's position and honor
our own purpose and assignment and if we
see a selfless being that is here for
love we have to give loyalty and if we
don't we deprive ourselves from Clear
guidance because you have to trust
someone who selfless will never harm you
but someone whose uh Authority is built
on ego it will but you have to also
understand a selfless person who has
reflected to you your inferiority and
Shadow aspects of looking up to a
teacher that has to be resolved because
that that that was not meant to hurt you
or to betray you it was just a
reflection and this is what also a lot
of mirrors are hated by many people I
know V and V Wong I know like they're
usually really hated by many and loved
by a view because those view who are
truly loyal they realize their true
nature through those teachers and
they're
grateful Adida for instance he also was
someone who's like unconditionally trust
me or get the [__] away from here and he
has disciples who are forever loyal to
him because they realize their true
nature through him and there's many
people that portray him as an evil being
but guess what they're not enlightened
they're just triggered in their own
shadow he just mirrored [__] to them and
they made an arrogant story out of it
and started to bash him but why how can
a person be bad if there's so many
people that say I got I reach my true
nature through that person like that
person helped me to get to my true
nature so how can that person be bad
we're only just mirrors for each other I
can I can call someone
queen and I can call someone a
[__] I'm a mirror in both I love you but
you need in this moment this piece of
paper and in that other moment you need
that kind of paper but trust me that I'm
here not to harm anyone and trust me
that I'm the mother I love Nikki more
than anyone else in
her family and and in her
friendships nobody loves her more than I
do only her mother and I would I know
I'm not sure if her mother will say it
but only I would dare to say it you're a
[__] she isn't but I just said that to
sh shook her up and shock her to shock
to shock that program yeah to shock that
program because she was almost get
heading there she's a beautiful woman if
she was a complete [__] who was help
hopeless and will never return I would
not even take the energy I would just
block her and that's it you you have
been you have been a catalyst for sexual
honor you have been a catalyst for
sexual honor yeah
apparently yeah it's beautiful yeah I
love it I love full circle so cool so
cool true true true true full circle
let's let's all uh let's all see what
happens when we uh sit in sexual honor
and that
ignites yeah how that ignites Divine
unions new Earth all that stuff love it
we need to find you a wife
man we we may be we may be in route we
may be in route who know because yeah I
think you should send me this video so I
can upload it to my page because there
are like a lot of feminine uh women
they're not triggered by me because
they're just like the fact that I just
also share feminine energy on my page
which is actually there's where my page
is for actually for women to inspire and
honor them and um help them return back
to their Essence as a true feminine
woman who's not depolarized and and in
that I see that very feminine women
they're becoming followers of my page uh
and the more depolarized women that are
like a boss [__] and and feminists
they're triggered by me and they don't
recognize me and and they they just
think I'm weird like they they they just
see a shadow in me that just really um
triggers them and I can see that it's
okay uh but I will continue speaking my
truth beautiful I'm looking forward to
continuing to play it'll be really
exciting how how the ignition has
happened and then how we came here and
did this and then there we go let's see
how it keeps you found me already like
two years ago how did you come across
like through my YouTube channel
something like that I'm not sure how it
in mon two years ago yeah but yeah but
but holy cow was that in a way kind of
like initiating for this cuz there was
that trust that was built there and then
now we're yeah we're here yeah yeah well
you invited me back back back in the day
like you said to me to join for the
podcast yeah for sure that you were
resonating the way that you were
speaking was resonating for sure yeah
but I remember you also told me like hey
um if you come into this Wing the wing
will protect you you also invited me
into the monastery but I remember at
that time I was very hesitant into
joining the monastery because you were a
man and me entering the monastery
through a man felt a bit I don't know I
was in my feminine energy so I felt a
bit I needed a I needed a female to
assure me that I am safe if I enter that
space so that's why we started chatting
with at with uh Corey and that other guy
that she was with and then we planned on
doing uh doing
a a dinner together with the four of us
but she didn't make me feel
safe because she was also being
Dishonored by the guy that was there so
I didn't feel safe as a woman entering
that that that field there because there
was no feminine woman there were no
women that truly made me feel uh as if I
could have a friendship with then and be
safe there in my feminine energy because
you have to understand if I go and and
and meet people somewhere and spend um a
lot of time there and there's also men
there I need to feel safe yes and if I
don't feel safe I'm not going to come in
and so you you would feel you you would
feel safe if the sexual honor was being
radi radiated around yeah yeah if she if
she could assure
me and that's that's a fascinating point
because that's exactly what's being
reflected here about the shadowy sides
of of spirituality because if there was
that sexual honor that's there which has
beautifully been reflected by the
mouthpiece that uh for the whole it's
then their safety for I love that
that's and that was because there was
this Antichrist there in the monastery
the depolarized feminine energy that was
not offering the authority the uh
rebalancing aspect of Love Cory was not
offering feminine energy to you guys
there
she was being the mother there she had
that position she didn't fulfill her
role she didn't support the masculine
she seduced you guys into the Antichrist
basically by allowing things that should
not be allowed a woman should know that
a woman knows well well just also just
to be clear again uh this is another one
of those things that's probably I don't
have enough context for these types of
things and this is more of like a round
tape more more of like a round table
thing Cory gave important Reflections
for me on the journey and also I agree
with what you were talking about
regarding regarding the SE regarding the
Divinity of of of SE of sexual sacred
Union and with being in in Balance but
also in your um femininity or in your
masculinity Etc I agree I agree just
that that's another thing and I don't I
actually would prefer to me to mediate
those things in a different you know
within in a more contextual way in a
more holistic way in a more roundt like
way so I would just like to also mention
that on this episode is that I very much
have had a long life of mediator
credentials I was a soccer referee from
when I was 11 years old until 21 so I've
always I've I always had to balance it
in sports by being a referee and then I
also was in debate and in debate I
qualified as an alternative for
Nationals in debate and in debate you
would do a coin flip before you would
start and that would determine if you're
arguing Pro or against some resolution
like the United States should uh
increase geopolitical relations with
China or something like that you know
something like that so right I have that
mediator credential plus I've also been
an international Diplomat in the way
that I've even traveled to different
places like China I have a whole Library
catalog on my channel of interviews that
I did in China with different professors
and scientists and things like that so I
have a big quote mediator background and
so I'm very I'm very excited to be being
asked by the field to step into this
okay at first there was a bit of
hesitation because of the amount of
drama and whatnot and that was reflected
in the conversations of the two plus
parties that were calling and asking for
me to do I didn't have any drama I was
enjoying myself like yeah so one sec so
so so then so so then then then then it
was fascinating cuz there was the
liberation of the mouthpiece and like
that masculine ra
like you know I'm I'm I'm here for this
like I'm here for this so I will gladly
I will gladly mediate from from that
place whatever holistic Roundtable
clearances uh new Earth frequencies
gladly gladly with love with emptiness
with joy with Grace with all of those
things so so I love like that's such a
perfect WAP for me on on it what what do
you how do you feel yeah I like that and
you can see now that God is placing you
into this ative role you know it's
because apparently that's part of your
purpose and it's beautiful like we all
came here to fulfill a purpose and
that's the most joyful thing there is
and yes things have went down the way
they went down because things were the
way they were and now we have have
gotten a greater uh Clarity and
reflection and out of the greater
Clarity
and um arises a greater
responsibility because we have a higher
mission to serve right now with all of
us because new Earth is not so far away
it's already very close and we have the
very direct tools and steps how to get
there it's just that we didn't expect
that it would be so obvious as it is sex
I mean that's the the the way to hien or
lower your Sexual Energy your life force
energy your vibration so it's like oh
everyone is like yeah okay it's actually
not new but it's like a complete blind
spot and this is like the function of
the Antichrist it's to seduce you into
something that's so obvious and to
portray that as something very
unimportant and and therefore the the
the the responsibility and the fault is
always with the women because that's how
Eve Adam and Eve the eve seduced Adam
not Adam Eve it's the original story of
Corruption of sin the woman is
responsible to say to a man if you want
me we have to get married and he will do
so all men that have heard me talk about
marriage respected me even more than the
second before I talked about it so a
woman is in her sexual honor through
that simple line of code which is if you
want this you have to marry me and yeah
yeah that's and that and that's in some
ways that ignites the masculine honor is
a reflection of like wow like what is
what is the gift what are the gifts that
are in store if I can finally be
sexually honorable yeah because they
feel that's loyalty because they feel
your loyalty to God and to yourself and
they're attracted to that because men
are not looking for sex with a woman
otherwise they would marry a prostitute
they're looking for loyalty so when they
sense loyalty and you happen to not be
all too ugly and not all too crazy but
but some people already already in love
with the psycho but if you're like okay
not too crazy they already want to marry
you they already want to marry you
because they men love loyalty that's
what they want from a woman and if a
woman can offer them that in these rare
times where loyalty is still like
important deemed to be important they
want that so I'm sure that a lot of
awake men who will watch this podcast
will get reminded oh yeah that's
actually what I want I want the true
woman sit in it yeah baby sit in it
let's go let's go strengthen that sexual
honor guys let's go let's go how
beautiful is that let's go yeah let's go
fam let's go so thank you so much thank
you thank you maram thank you thank you
um so okay so I will I will send this
also to to you you said you wanted to to
did you say you wanted to post it do you
want to do you want me to send you the
full yes you don't know you mean you
want me to send the full video you want
me to send the
full so there's like uh followers of my
page who are also looking there's many
women that come and comment uh like send
me messages and stuff they like yeah I
really want to meet the one and I
they're impacted by my messages and I'm
like almost ready like I don't work so
someone else has to take this in hands
but this is the the greatest impact that
we can make is we when form unions and
rebalance or masculine and feminine
energy and feel protected and provided
for again and feel loved and enaged and
supported so we need some kind of uh if
we talk about those like systems to
build one of the first syst Divine like
a Divine like a Divine union network
Divine union network because someone
already offered their service to me but
it's just that I don't have the skills
to manage other people like I'm not a
manager or a boss or whatever someone
else has to arrange that someone offered
their service already he said like I can
set up some sort of like a uh internet
system for like dating like dating for
unions to be formed within people for
people to be able to meet each other
through my energy you know through what
I talk about and people that feel
attracted to what I say about the new
Earth and divine Union someone's asking
to make a system for the thing that that
you were talking about yeah
that would be wonderful for divine for
divine sexual honor unions yeah nice yes
nice that's that's that's exciting okay
cool cool okay so there's all of these
ways to to help and and play I love that
and um okay I already I think I already
shared I'll do it one more time this is
uh the links are in the description this
is uh we have mariam's website we have
her her YouTube channel here and we have
her Instagram where she's uh pretty
active on the stories but you have to
you have to follow right you said there
follow on the stories calling people
[__] and Cs and I'm
like Hood gangster you you you recently
said no no leeches so does that mean
people now have to um request to follow
you is that what you were saying to me
yeah because there was a lot of people
that were constantly every day coming on
my Instagram page but they were too
afraid to hit the follow button so then
I was be like okay and end the
leeching practice and tradition so now
you now you have to be followed in order
for people to see your story okay cool
cool all right so um That's all folks if
the video uh brought you exciting
Catalyst value you know give it a like
subscribe comment below um share the
video you know all the good stuff um all
right uh that's that's pretty much it oh
yeah we got the home da also we got a
lot of projects in the in the
description home da is one of the best
ones decentralizing basic needs
infrastructures and activating Earth's
freedom for all so let's go let's go
free freedom freedom freedom and Love
Freedom and love byee thank you so much
hey one second let me one second let me
end the stream and then one second let
me just end the stream and then we'll
stay for a minute okay one second